Number two, confusion and misinformation
about the godhead and the trinity. Let
me tell you
probably after this sermon,
Magdal
Perez Schulz, my extremely able
assistant,
he's the one who receives or Marilyn
Perez, my executive assistant. They will
receive
messages
Why did Wilson say that? Wilson is
wrong.
I want to tell you today
I am telling you
from my perspective
what the Bible says
the trinity 7th day adventist believe
there is one God and that this one God
is three co-eternal persons who work
together in unity. Amen.
We fully embrace our fundamental belief
number two, which indicates that the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit
have always been and always will be.
Make no mistake about it. The divine
trinity work in unison as one within the
Godhead from eternity to eternity.
Allow God to use you, every one of you,
to share this wonderful truth of a
triune God who is carrying out his plan
of salvation for each of us.
Welcome everyone. Thank you for being
here. Let me get a quick drink of my tea
here.
I want to give a big shout out to Banner
of Truth. No, this is not uh paid
advertising,
though you guys can reach out to me if
you would like. I am a big supporter of
Banner of Truth. But big shout out to
Ted Wilson as well for that great
introduction as tonight we will be
examining the Adventist pioneers in
light of their views regarding the
Trinity as well as who they believed
Jesus Christ to be. What you could call
christologology.
There has been a growing rift within the
uh SDA sect for quite some time over
this exact issue which you could kind of
pick up there from what Ted said is
going to happen. Some of you may have
seen it. We looked at all of that
address a few months ago which uh that
clip was obviously pulled from and he
was addressing this issue because it is
growing within their movement. It is
something that will never be resolved
though unless the roots of the movement
are sprayed with uh theological
glyphosate if you will and killed until
they are ready to renounce their
pioneers. This problem will persist.
But it's important that we address this
because
as we also heard, Ted wants us to
believe like many others in their
movement that they are trinitarians.
Now, I've said and I will continue to
say this is just Christian ease. And
what I mean by that is it is the
borrowing of Christian language but
meaning something entirely different. We
heard for example how the Adventist
heavenly trio is one in a mission and
purpose and that's what makes them one
God supposedly.
But being united in a mission is not
what makes monotheism monotheistic.
Which is why the Christian church who
was led by God early on developed
language around this subject that
articulates with specificity what the
scriptures are saying on this subject.
At the end of the day that's what
matters at least on this platform. What
does scripture teach and what do we mean
by the words that we use? Not just that
we use all the right words which is key.
And that's precisely uh what we will be
starting by doing before conducting the
funeral service of the pioneers. But to
get specific,
we obviously always on this platform
love to start with a thesis.
One of the central claims of the SDA
church is that we're supposed to believe
that God raised them up as his last day
people to restore the fullness of
apostolic Christianity. We also saw that
from Ted Wilson last week. So our thesis
for tonight is going to be answering the
question, are these the individuals
who the true God, the triune God, raised
up to restore his church as his end
times remnant people?
Are these the individuals that God
raised up to restore his church as his
end times remnant people? because that
is a central claim of theirs.
Now, Ted mentioned some other things
which we'll also look at in conjunction
with this subject such as the uh plan of
salvation, but we will look at that more
closely toward the end as we wrap things
up. This is going to be a very long
presentation, folks, but a very
important one. It has been in the making
for a long time, and it just needs to to
be done in one sitting. So, that's just
the heads up, the disclaimer. It is
going to be a long night. We will start
by laying out the fundamentals of the
trinity, the biblical basis for such.
Then we will look at our SDA sources in
light of the biblical witness. The stuff
I am sharing tonight is not unique to
me. This is not answering Adventism's uh
fancy. This is not something I just came
up with. Um sharing is caring. I say
that a lot on this platform. That's
what's happening here. Sharing is
caring. I stand on the shoulders of
giants. So, we have lots of sources to
look at. But before doing that,
I got to tell you guys about a new thing
on the channel. Our member section is
now live, which means you can join and
gain access to exclusive content. And as
things move along, other tiers will be
added, uh, which will include things
like merchandise, private Q&A sessions,
community hangouts, and a whole bunch
more depending on how things go. We get
a lot of people wanting to talk on the
phone, Zoom calls, etc., and there is
just no possible way to meet all of
those requests. I want to meet them. I
always feel terrible when I can't with
people, but there are just so many that
it's not realistic. That would be my
full-time job if I were doing this. Um,
which is why we will soon be expanding
the membership tiers to include one that
will have a weekly Q&A as well as
potentially some one-on-one type
sessions, etc. Again, I get a lot of
Christians as well that want to have
long discussions regarding how to reach
people apologetically in their community
and so forth. So, click the members link
down in the description box if this is
something of interest to you. It'll take
you to the YouTube homepage where you
can sign up directly to what you see on
your screen. You can become a member and
get plugged into some of the new avenues
we plan to explore. Uh mainly around
connecting with the audience more. It is
hard to do that in these presentations
without getting sidetracked. I'm
notoriously known for being uh rather
long- winded or verbose sometimes. Um,
and so it is hard to uh engage with the
audience during these presentations
without them being uh a lot longer than
they already are. But I do want to
interact with you all more and we will
be doing a lot more uh stuff and
interaction in the members community.
So to start
breaking the ice on all of this on this
subject folks there is something you
have to understand and that is
the difference
between
the doctrine of the trinity and the
biblical evidence for the trinity.
Anti-trinitarians of all stripes
get confused in this area which leads to
all sorts of faulty conclusions and
ideas.
So first
the doctrine of the trinity
is not the biblical evidence. Like I
said, the doctrine refers to the
language and words that the Christian
church has used to accurately describe
what the Bible teaches about the father,
son, and holy spirit. The language is
used to describe the godhead. So the
examples being and persons,
those words are used for very specific
reasons.
When you hear the argument those words,
that's that's not in the Bible. This is
the doctrine of the trinity. It is the
language that we are trying to use to
accurately convey what the Bible is
teaching in clearer in in like a more
formalized and clear a accurate
representation of what's there. The
biblical evidence on the other hand is
looking at the Bible in its entirety to
see what it says regarding Christ, the
father, the holy spirit, their
characteristics and attributes etc. So,
it is pointing to biblical passages, but
the doctrine may use language. Yes, the
word trinity is not found in the Bible.
That's not the claim. That's not the
point. It doesn't need to be in the
Bible. We talked a little bit last week.
There's no example of a woman taking
communion in the Bible. That doesn't
mean women should not take communion.
It doesn't mean the Bible doesn't teach
that women should take communion.
So, understand the distinction between
the doctrine of the Trinity and the
biblical evidence for the Trinity. When
people use those silly arguments like
the word Trinity isn't found in the
Bible, they're conflating and crossing
wires. For one, neither is the word
Bible. So, they just shot themselves in
the foot. But second, it doesn't need to
be. Again, that's not the claim because
what we mean when we use the the word
Trinity is found in scripture.
The word is simply a summation word to
summarize a lot of information. So we
use language such as person and being to
describe areas of unity and areas of
distinction.
What you really when you're getting
technical is the one in the many.
So in order to accurately describe that
theologians the church essentially
through the years dealing with heresies
like Aryanism, semi-aranism, uticianism,
nnosticism
have used words per the words person and
being to distinguish areas of unity and
distinction
both of which we do see in the Bible.
God is both totally united. But there is
also a distinction regarding the father
not being the son, the son not being the
spirit, the spirit not being the father,
etc. So to distinguish between these
areas and remain precise, we use certain
words to convey that without falling
into polytheism with multiple gods or a
unitarian position where only the father
for example is the eternal god. Um
something to that effect. So that is
one. Understand that the doctrine of the
trinity is not the same as the biblical
evidence for the trinity. We will be
looking at both. So the doctrine of the
trinity specifically is this.
In the most simple of terms,
within the one being that is God, there
exists eternally three co-eternal and
co-equal persons, namely the father,
son, and the spirit. Did you notice that
Ted in the introduction, now I'm not
saying that he did this purposefully or
what have you. I'm just making a a
recognition. And this guy has a bad
track record, folks. He just made a
video for the SDA church's YouTube
channel a couple weeks ago where he
described the the Trinity as modalism.
So, I'm not sure. I I think Ted is a
good parrot, but I don't think Ted
actually is a good theologian. But did
you notice in the introduction, he did
not say that they are co-equal.
He said co-eternal persons but formally
speaking within the one being that is
God there exists eternally three
co-equal and co-eternal persons namely
the father son and the spirit.
So God is one singular being
and that one being exists in three
co-equal co-eternal persons the father
son and the spirit. When we use the
words person and being, this is what we
mean.
Person refers to the conscious ability
to will, speak, self-reflect, exhibit
emotions, etc.
Being refers to the mode or state of
existence.
You have to understand this distinction
here.
This cup has being. It does not have
personhood.
I have being and personhood. I'm one
being, one person.
In a lot of people's minds, person is
synonymous with human or human being.
That's not the way it's being used here.
Human beings are both one being and one
person.
Angels also have personhood and they are
not human beings. Spirits have
personhood and are not human beings. So
when Christians say we believe in the
three co-equal, co-eternal persons, that
is what we are referring to.
Father, son, and spirit can all speak,
self-reflect, exhibit emotions. That's
what we see in scripture. They are all
conscious.
When we use the term being, we are
returning to we are referring to the
mode of something or someone's
existence.
I'm one person, one singular being. But
God is three persons, one being. There's
only one mode of existence that is God.
One singular being that that that is the
I am.
And that one being is shared by these
three persons. They're not it's not 33%
33% 33%. No, no, no. This the one being
the one God is father, son, and spirit.
They're not self-existent.
It's not three standalone self-existent.
We'll get into all that. But another way
of thinking of this is that the being
describes the what of God
and the persons describe the who.
So there's one what, three who's.
So the three doctrinal pillars
of the trinity look like this.
There is one being that is God.
Monotheism.
There are three divine persons
and the three persons are co-equal and
co-eternal.
This is why folks the language around
person and being is so important. And
when they b and scoff and say that's
Greek philosophy or that they don't
understand the issue that it has nothing
to do with any of that. You're also
pointing at people that lived in a
different time period and then faulting
them for their time period. It'll be
interesting to see if if the world goes
on for 500 more years, this movement is
not going to be around if things go on
for 500 years. Is it really imminency if
it's been 700 years? You know, so if it
goes along for 500 more years, um would
it be fair for the people if the
movement is still around for people
Adventists in the future to point back
to Adventist of this day 500 years
removed and say, "Oh, that's that's
American philosophy."
Well, yeah, because the movement was
born in America. So there's certain
aspects that uh these these excuses are
irrelevant because what matters is
what's really being said, the substance
of what's being said and that is present
in the text. I pointed out how recently
the SDA church updated their website
regarding the trinity that was in a
short that we put up on the website uh
or rather on the YouTube channel. Uh it
used to say they believe God is three
eternal beings. They switched this to
three eternal persons, but it says
nothing regarding the being.
Tritheist folks believe in three
persons.
Tritheism
groups that believe in three gods.
They believe in three persons. So you
have to say, well, no, it's three three
persons, one being.
So only saying three persons doesn't
mean that they are trinitarian. They
refuse to add that God is only one
being.
And the excuse that I've heard is, well,
we just don't use that language because
the Bible doesn't. Well, the Bible
doesn't say God is three persons
verbatim either, but they have no
problem saying that. The real reason for
this will be made evident once we get
into looking at the pioneers and the way
that they used language, most
specifically Ellen White. But that is
the doctrine of the trinity. We will
look at the biblical evidence in a
moment. But there is another aspect of
this discussion that we uh that has to
be understood and that is the economics
and ontology of God. Now these might
sound like big fancy words etc but
they're really we'll get into that. This
is where people will often get confused
because they say they they see Jesus the
son doing something distinct from the
father. for example like the incarnation
or dying on the cross and they struggle
to see how Jesus could be completely
equal with the father. Then
this is because there are two ways of
discussing God and his doings.
The economics of the trinity refers to
the roles that each person of the
godhead assumes in redemptive history.
So the father did not incarnate, the son
did.
The holy spirit did not die on the
cross, the son did, etc. The difference
in that context is in function.
That does not make them unequal in
being, which is what ontology is, the
stud the the the science of being.
So when we talk about the ontological
trinity, we're talking in the context of
who God is at the being level. When you
talk about the economics of the trinity,
you're talking about how each person
functions differently in redemption.
Which is why we have the ontology of the
trinity or what some theologians will
call the imminence of the trinity.
I m M A N E N CE iminence not like the
imminent return but iminence
this refers to God's actual being
without regard to his works of creation
and redemption. So the ontological
structure of the trinity is a unity.
Deuteronomy 6:4, the schma.
When we speak of the economics of the
Trinity, on the other hand, we're
dealing with the activity of God and the
roles of the three persons regarding
creation and redemption.
The reason that this is important to
understand is because we have to think
in proper categories. There are times
people will point to distinctions within
the Godhead and they don't recognize
it's a distinction in function, not
being. That's the key.
This also gets into what's called the
the hypothatic union. The two natures of
Christ ascribed to the single person. He
is the God man. He's fully God, fully
man. We see divine attributes ascribed
to the Lord Jesus like we will see
momentarily. But we also see human
attribution ascribed to the same person.
He gets tired. He has to go to the
bathroom. God doesn't have to go to the
bathroom. So people will often say, I'm
not saying SDAs will say this, but
anti-trinitarians oftentimes will say
things like, "So you're saying if Jesus
is God, how do God doesn't have to
sleep? God doesn't get tired." Right?
Because the unique son of God in the
incarnation is both fully man and fully
God. So in his humanity, of course, he
got tired. Of course, he he was truly
human,
but he's also truly God. Like we're
going to see the the Bible also ascribes
divinity to him.
So often times I say that to say people
will point to these things these these
differences or these things that seem
human to say well God doesn't get tired
etc. And it's because they don't
understand these things are ultimately
in the context of the economics of God
not the being of God.
So when Jesus for example submits to the
will of the father and suffers as the
suffering servant Isaiah foretold you'll
get people that will say this shows
Jesus isn't ontologically equal with the
father but no this is a distinction in
function and role not being.
Jesus willfully chose to assume that
role from eternity past as the suffering
servant.
The father didn't do that. The the
spirit didn't do that. But that doesn't
mean that in their being they're not
equal. These two categories simply help
us keep categorical distinctions clear
and to not muddy the waters. Now when it
comes to the Adventist heavenly trio,
which is the term Ellen White used to
refer to the Godhead, what makes them
one is not their ontology.
The heavenly trio is three distinct
persons who all possess their own
distinct being.
It is three persons, three beings,
which is why they are functionally
tritheus. The key word being
functionally. They're going to insist
and tell you, "No, we're not. No, we're
not."
But functionally, they have three gods
with the father alone being the
almighty, which I will back up with why
I'm saying this. But as Ted mentioned in
that opening clip and as uh can be seen
on their website, they teach what makes
their gods uh what makes their gods one
is a mission and a purpose.
Notice what Ellen White says regarding
this trio.
This is from a very long titled
Testimonies for the church containing
messages of warning and instruction for
7th Day Adventists page 63.
Quote, "The comforter that Christ
promised to send after he ascended to
heaven is the spirit in all the fullness
of the Godhead, making manifest the
power of divine grace to all who receive
and believe in Christ as personal
savior.
There are three living persons of the
heavenly trio. In the name of these
three great powers,
the father, the son, and the holy
spirit. Those who receive Christ by
living faith are baptized. And these
powers
will cor will cooperate with the
obedient subjects of heaven in their
efforts to live the new life in Christ.
Close quote.
God is not a trio, folks.
Nor is God three great powers.
But this is how the Adventist God
God is one.
They are united in the plan of salvation
and cooperate with those who decide to
be obedient in bringing about a person's
new life in Christ. We looked at some of
that last week. their hyper synergistic
system.
Now notice though what she says
regarding Jesus's existence.
Quote, this is from Signs of the Times,
August 29, 1900, 15 years before her
death.
Christ is the pre-existent,
selfexistent
son of God. In speaking of his
pre-existence, Christ carries the mind
back through dateless ages. close quote.
Adventists will bicker amongst
themselves over statements like this,
folks. The anti- the anti-heavenly trio
crowd says, "She's simply affirming what
some of the pioneers did, that Jesus's
beginning was so far in the distant
past, you could basically call it
eternal." The pro-heavenly trio crowd
tries saying this proof she claimed that
Jesus has always existed. More on this
when we look at the pioneers. But the
issue with this statement, folks, is no,
Jesus is not self-existent.
And I've yet to meet the SDA that
understands the severity of this claim.
I'll explain this now with a visual aid.
The Trinity Shield on the left is a
common graphic that is used to convey
what Trinitarians are saying.
Not a threeleaf clover. That's modalism.
Or even getting into uticianism, parting
out God.
But you'll see there is a connectedness
and a plurality to the triune God. The
father isn't the son. The son isn't the
father. Yet they are all one singular
being.
The father is not self-existent. The son
is not self-existent. The Holy Spirit is
not self-existent.
The three persons make up the one God.
Again, the father isn't 33%, the son
another 33, etc. There's no division at
that level. The one God is father, son,
and spirit. And that one being is
self-existent.
Just like at the at the baptism of a
believer, they are baptized. The the
initiation into the church is in the
name of the one God. The name singular,
father, son, and spirit. God is not like
anything in creation, folks. We don't
know the inner workings and mechanics of
how God is the way he is. Scripture does
not tell us all of that. And honestly,
that's part of the beauty of betraying
God. He is unsearchable such that the
depths of who he is will leave us in awe
and wonder for all of eternity. The
Adventist heavenly trio on the other
hand are three distinct beings
self-existent alongside one another. And
what makes them one is not their being
and state of existence but their mission
and purpose
which this is what their website still
states. They believe these three beings,
this trio, works together like a team in
the plan of redemption and they're
united on that plan. So therefore, that
makes them one god.
But no, that that's not one god. That
would be like saying if the Greek
pantheon, Zeus, Athena, etc., if they
were real hypothetically and they
weren't all fighting for supremacy but
they united in a mission where they were
never at cross purposes that all of a
sudden now you have one god
which is an actual example we will look
at momentarily from one of their
scholars.
So all of that to say that is the
doctrine of the trinity in a nutshell.
the doctrine
as well as the distinction between the
economics and the ontology
of the Trinity.
With that laid out, now let's look at uh
let's look at the biblical evidence for
the Trinity.
What was essentially examined by the
church very early on. This is old,
folks. This is not this is not new.
Which is why this is such a big issue
because
when you come along in the 19th century
and claim that Christians have been
worshiping an idol for nearly 2,000
years, yeah, you're going to have some
serious problems.
But let let's look at the biblical
evidence now.
That's what was looked at by the church
to arrive at this language and and
presentation. I'll start by saying this
will be by no means exhaustive. The
whole presentation could be on example
after example after example of
scripture, hundreds of examples. We
could spend the whole night on that. But
let's establish from scripture that the
father, son, and spirit are all the one
eternal God, the almighty. Okay? Let's
start with Jesus being the almighty.
Notice what Jesus says in Mark 2 1-1.
And when he returned to Capernaum after
some days, it was reported that he was
at home. And many were gathered together
so that there was no more room, not even
at the door. And he talking about Christ
was preaching the word to them. And they
came bringing bringing him a paralytic
carried by four men. And when they could
not near him be and when they could not
get near him because of the crowd, they
removed the roof above him. And when
they had made an opening, they let down
the bed on which the paralytic lay. And
when Jesus saw their faith, he said to
the paralytic,
"Son, your sins are forgiven."
Now, some of the scribes were sitting
there questioning in their hearts,
"Why does this man speak like that? He
is blaspheing. Who can forgive sins but
God alone?"
And immediately Jesus perceiving in his
spirit that they thus questioned within
themselves, said to them, "Why do you
question these things in your hearts?"
Which is easier to say to the paralytic,
"Your sins are forgiven." Or to say,
"Rise, take up your bed, and walk?" But
that you may know that the Son of Man
has authority on earth to forgive sins.
He said to the paralytic, I say to you,
rise, pick up your bed, and go home. And
thus, the reading of God's holy word.
Something important to catch before we
get into breaking this down. When
scripture uses the phrase in his spirit
to refer to Christ, that is the author
speaking about his divine nature.
when they use the phrase according to
the flesh, that is them referring to his
human nature, such as in Romans 1:3 and
uh Romans 9:5.
But notice in this encounter, Jesus
forgives the paralytic sins.
He knew what was in the hearts of the
Pharisees and he healed the physical and
spiritual disease of the paralytic.
He not only healed him physically, he
healed him spiritually.
So, three things Jesus did in this one
single encounter.
Well, first Kings 8:39 says that Yahweh
alone
forgives sins.
Psalm 44:21 says God knows the secrets
of the heart.
And Psalm 103:2 through3 says, "Yahweh,
Jehovah, the Almighty, heals diseases
and forgives sins."
Jesus does all three in this single
instance. Hence why the Pharisees who
would have been familiar with the Old
Testament said what they did. Only God
can do what this man is claiming to do.
But this shows that Jesus is not some
lesser divine being.
Now
Isaiah says that Yahweh is the first and
the last, the only savior.
Notice Isaiah 43:10-11.
You are my witnesses, declares the Lord.
The Lord there, that's Yahweh,
the Almighty.
Not some, not like Abraham was referred
to by his wife Sarah, who called him
Lord. No, that's lowercase L. Lord. This
is the Almighty Yahweh, Jehovah. You are
my witnesses, declares the Lord, and my
servant whom I have chosen, that you may
know and believe me, and understand that
I am he. Before me, no God was formed,
lowercase G. Nor shall there be any
after me. I I am the Lord, the Almighty,
and besides me,
there is no what?
Savior.
Yahweh is the only savior.
And then notice Isaiah 44 6-8.
Thus says the Lord, the the King of
Israel and the Redeemer, the Lord of
Hosts.
I am the first, I am the last. Who is
speaking, folks? The Almighty.
Besides me, there is no God. Just said
that the previous chapter
who is like me. Let him proclaim it. Let
him declare and set it before me. Since
I appointed an ancient people, let them
declare what is to come and what will
happen. Fear not, nor be afraid. Have I
not told you from of old and declared
it? And are you not and are you my
witnesses? Is there a God besides me?
Capital G. Is there an Almighty besides
me?
So, not only does Yahweh say, "There's
not even an idol that's like me. You're
not even going to find another Almighty
that is like me. There is no rock
capital R. I know not any.
Thus the reading of God's holy word. So
Yahweh clearly tells us he is the only
God. There are none besides him. He's
the first and the last.
The only savior. Only savior. He's the
only rock
which is a recurring image in the Old
Testament for God. Capital R.
Well, folks, Jesus explicitly states
that he is the first and the last, the
Almighty, multiple times in Revelation
alone.
Notice all the passages referring to
Jesus and Jesus speaking,
calling himself the first and the last,
alpha and omega, the Almighty.
Revelation 18, I am the Alpha and the
Omega, says the Lord God, who is and who
was and who is to come, the Almighty.
same chapter in 17 and 18. You'll get
some people say that's not Jesus
speaking in verse 8. Okay. When I saw
him, this is John. I fell at his feet as
though dead, but he laid his right hand
on me, saying, "Fear not. I am the first
and the last, the living one. I died and
behold, I am alive forever more and I
have the keys of death in Hades." It's
Jesus, folks. That'll be read in your
red letter Bible.
Yahweh just told us through Isaiah. He's
the first and the last. There's no God
beside him. He's the almighty. Jesus is
the first and the last. Revelation 2:8
again, Jesus speaking and to the angel
of the church in Smyrna, right? This is
him telling John the words of the first
and the last who died and came to life.
We're told in Titus 2:13
that Jesus is our great God and savior.
Did Yahweh say it through Isaiah? He's
the only savior
waiting for our blessed hope, the
appearing of the glory of our great God
and savior Jesus Christ. This is what's
called a Granville sharp construction.
You'll get people that try to claim,
"No, no, no, no. The great God is
referring to the father and then savior
is referring to Jesus Christ." Yeah,
that backfires on you. Yahweh says
through Isaiah, he's the only savior.
So, it doesn't work. Nice try. 2 Timothy
1:10
and which now has been manifested
through the appearing of our savior
Christ Jesus who abolished death and
brought life ah has the keys of death
and hades
and immortality to light through the
gospel
which means if according to Isaiah
Yahweh alone is the first and the last
the only savior that means Jesus is the
almighty not just this but Yahweh says
he alone is the only rock. What does
Paul tell us in 1 Corinthians 10?
For I do not want you to be unaware,
brothers, that our fathers, the
Israelites, were all under the cloud,
and all passed through the sea, that's
the Red Sea, and were all baptized into
Moses in the cloud and in the sea. And
all ate of the same spiritual food, and
all drank the same spiritual drink. For
they drank from the spiritual rock,
capital R, that followed them. And the
rock
was Christ.
Jesus was with Israel in the Old
Testament and he was the what?
The rock.
Remember in Numbers, Moses striking the
rock or actually not striking the rock
when he was supposed to.
That was a type and a shadow of Jesus
being struck and bruised for our
iniquities. He was that rock.
Living streams of water poured out of
the rock.
The rock was a picture and a type of
Christ who was there and was present. He
was that spiritual rock.
But Yahweh says through Isaiah that he
alone is the rock and there are no
others.
Jesus is Yahweh. Again, Isaiah 44, God
through the prophet. same chapter we
were just in tells us a number of
things. But first notice Isaiah 44:24.
Thus says the Lord your redeemer who
formed you from the womb. I am the Lord
who made all things
who alone alone stretched out the
heavens who spread out the earth by
myself.
So the word Lord here is the name of God
translated Jehovah Yahweh whatever you
prefer. The point being it is the
Almighty, not simply a lord like David
was called lower lowercase L. But the
Almighty says that he alone stretched
out the heavens and made all things. He
did this by himself.
Yahweh is also the believer's redeemer.
We just saw that in the previous chapter
as well
or savior if you will, which he said in
the previous chapter. There's only one
savior.
Well, looking at the entirety of the
biblical witness, which is how the
Trinity is arrived at, Paul and John
both tell us that Jesus made all things.
But just a couple of places out of a
plethora regarding the work of work of
creation, Colossians 1:15-17 and Hebrews
1:10,
he is the image of the invisible God,
the firstborn of all creation. For by
him, notice that folks, by him all
things were created, in heaven and on
earth, visible and invisible, whether
thrones or dominions or rulers or
authorities, all things were created.
Through him and for him, and he is
before all things, and in him all things
hold together. This is talking about
Jesus. And Hebrews 1:10 again talking
about Jesus. You Lord laid the
foundation of the earth in the
beginning. Not some lowercase Lord.
No, no. This Lord is the Almighty who
laid the foundations of the earth
and the heavens are the work of your
hands.
We will get to the term firstborn later.
But notice, all things were not merely
made through the Son like early SDA
pioneers and other cults like like the
Jehovah's Witnesses try and say. Paul
says all things were made by Jesus as
well. He laid the foundations of the
earth. Well, Yahweh through Isaiah said
that he alone made all things,
which means Jesus is almighty.
Like I said, we could spend all night
looking at Jesus' parallels and how he
is Yahweh, but that proves such. This
doesn't even get into the fact that
Deuteronomy 6 says that the Lord our God
is one, while Ephesians 4 says there's
only one Lord,
Jesus Christ, the Lord.
But the father is also called lord and
the spirit is called lord
evidencing that the one lord is the
almighty. Father, son, and spirit. But
that's the evidence that we'll look at
tonight for the son being Jehovah.
Now notice what the Almighty also who
who said this through Isaiah in 64:8
says,
"But now, oh Lord,
you are our father.
We are the clay and you are the potter.
We are all the work of your hand."
It's like what we see in Romans, Romans
chapter nine.
The father was also involved in
creation, which means the father is also
Jehovah, Yahweh.
Father and son both created.
Now, I've yet to run into the person
that denies the father is the almighty.
So, in the interest of time, we will let
that suffice.
I don't think I mean, if you're going to
make that argument, all right, we're
going to move along anyways.
Now, what about the Holy Spirit?
This is a big one, folks, because lots
of people, and we're going to get into
this,
try and say, "Well, the spirit is is
Jesus's spirit or the father's spirit."
It's
Genesis 1 1-2 says that the spirit of
God hovered over the face of the waters
followed by himself acting in creation.
So when creation began, the spirit is
already present. But the term hovering
is very important.
It actually has to do with being active
in creation.
How do we know this?
So notice Genesis 1 1-2.
In the beginning, God created the
heavens and the earth. The earth was
without form and void, and darkness was
over the face of the deep. And the
spirit of God was hovering over the face
of the waters.
But now notice Deuteronomy 32:11,
which says that Yahweh is like an eagle
that stirs up its nest and hovers
over its young
that spreads its wings to catch them and
carries them a loft.
So like an eagle that hovers over its
nest, feeding its young, caring for
them, etc.
So God hovers over his people.
You can look this up as I have and
that's why I know this. The same verb is
being used in Genesis 1 about the spirit
that's used here in Deuteronomy.
Meaning the spirit was doing the same
thing over the earth at creation,
evidencing that the Holy Spirit was also
involved in creation and he also is
almighty since the Almighty alone
created all things.
Yet the father, son, and spirit are
distinguished from one another at some
level. For example, in John 14:26,
Jesus says that when he ascends back to
the father, the holy spirit will then be
sent to comfort them.
Jesus doesn't say he'll send his spirit
to comfort them or the father will come
to comfort you. No, no. The Holy Spirit
is sent from the father and the son at
the ascension of Christ.
When Jesus is baptized, the spirit
descends on him in the likeness of a
dove. The father speaking the the
blessing over him at his baptism and the
son is there in the water. The spirit is
not the spirit of Christ. It's not the
spirit of the father. The spirit is a
distinct person.
The spirit is referred to with personal
male pronouns. He is a person. He has
the ability to act, will, speak, be
spoken to, etc. So, for example, in Acts
21,
Acts 21:8-11,
we see that the Holy Spirit can speak.
It says, "On the next day we departed
and came to Cesaria, and we entered the
house of Philip the evangelist,
who was one of the seven and stayed with
him. He had four unmarried daughters who
prophesied. While we were staying for
many days, a prophet named Agabus came
from Judea."
and coming to us. He took Paul's belt
and bound his own feet and hands and
said, "Thus says the Holy Spirit."
This is how the Jews at Jerusalem will
bind the man who owns this belt and
deliver him into the hands of the
Gentiles.
Very clearly,
Agabus spoke or or the Holy Spirit spoke
through Agabus.
We also read in Romans 8:26-7,
"Likewise, the Spirit helps us in our
weaknesses."
Helps us in our weaknesses, for we do
not know what to pray as we ought, but
the Spirit himself
intercedes for us with groanings too
deep for words. And he who does what?
Searches hearts.
What did we see earlier in first kings
8?
God Yahweh the Almighty is capable of
searching hearts.
And he who searches hearts knows what is
the mind of the spirit because the
spirit intercedes for the saints
according to the will of God.
Or sorry that's that's the Psalms that
God is the almighty is the one who
searches hearts. Lots of anti
anti-trinitarians, including tons of
Adventists, like to try and use the
argument that the Holy Spirit is either
Jesus's spirit or the father's spirit
when no very clearly he is distinguished
from both. But he's called the spirit of
the Lord, all caps, LD,
and the spirit or the spirit of Yahweh,
which we will look at shortly.
But it makes no sense, folks, to say God
knows the mind of the spirit if the
spirit if the spirit is God the father
because that would be saying God knows
his own mind.
Furthermore, how can the Holy Spirit
know how to intercede for us if he isn't
a person?
He's referred to as a he and himself. He
prays for all believers simultaneously,
knowing their struggles, and he can pray
for all of them simultaneously.
That is a divine attribute. Show me a
human that can do that.
Or a creature.
That is a divine attribute and shows he
is omnisient and omnipotent.
Now let's look at this even further.
Specifically the spirit of the lord.
Acts 5 is a bazooka.
It is a numlogical which is just the
study of the holy spirit. It is a
numatlogical
bazooka.
It just ends the the discussion. Praise
God for the apostle Peter in Acts 5.
When Peter's rebuking Ananas and Safh,
notice what he says. But a man named
Ananas and his wife Safh sold a piece of
property. And with his wife's knowledge,
he kept back for himself some of the
proceeds and brought only a part of it
and laid it at the apostles feet. But
Peter said, "Ananas, why has Satan
filled your heart to lie to the Holy
Spirit and to keep back for yourself
part of the proceeds of the land? While
it remained unsold, did it not remain
your own? And after it was sold, was it
not at your disposal?"
Why is it that you have contrived this
deed in your heart?
You have not lied to man,
but to God.
When Ananas heard these words, he fell
down and breathed his last, and great
fear came upon all who heard it. The
young man rose, or the young men rose
and wrapped him up and carried him out
and buried him.
After an interval of about 3 hours, his
wife came in, not knowing what had
happened.
And Peter said to her, "Tell me whether
you sold the land for so much." And she
said, "Yes, for so much."
But Peter said to her, "How is it that
you have agreed together to test the
spirit of the Lord,
behold, the feet of those who have
buried your husband are at the door, and
they will carry you out."
So Peter tells Ananas he didn't lie to
man but to God
and the Holy Spirit is who he lied to
which means the spirit is God. Even
further demonstrated in the fact that he
tells Safh they tested the spirit of
Yahweh the spirit of Jehovah the spirit
of the Lord.
This is the same spirit
or rather spirit of the Lord. Sorry.
This is the same spirit of the Lord that
Samuel in 2 Samuel uh 23:2 says spoke
through him.
Again evidencing that the Holy Spirit
can speak. He isn't just a force or a
procession
spirit of Yahweh.
Now that was only a sampling
but this is why the Christian church
believes in the doctrine of the trinity.
Because when we look at scripture in
total, we see that the father, son, and
spirit are all Yahweh.
But they have a level of distinction
that makes them different
economically
in the plan of redemption.
The father didn't die on the cross. The
father didn't incarnate.
The spirit didn't die on the cross. The
son didn't descend on the son in the
water at the baptism.
Yet at the same time,
they're all Yahweh.
So to uh uh to effectively communicate
this, we use the language of person and
being.
That's why they are such important
distinctions. Simply saying three
persons is not enough.
A tritheist can say the same thing,
folks, and then say, "Well, we're
monotheists." based on how Adventism
tries to to do it. Mormons are
polytheists and they'll tell you they
believe in three persons. Yet, they
believe in a vast number of of an
innumerable number of gods.
They'll say, "Oh, well, the the Trinity
is the three gods of this planet. We
only worship those gods because they
created our planet, but there's all
sorts of other gods out there."
So person and being I I just they're so
important in this and necessary in this
discussion whenever they use these silly
that's that's a you know I it depends
who you talk to but it's like you can
talk to some of their scholarly ones and
it's like oh well that's that's Thomas
Aquinus and it's it's just so laughable.
It's so laughable. It's like stop trying
to pawn this off on like all the
favorite boogeymen like oh that's Roman
Catholicism. Oh that's that's Greek
philosophy. Oh that's arisatilian. No.
deal with what's being said. Deal with
what's being said.
But in light of all of this, I want to
now transition into looking at some
statements from SDA history professor
Jerry Moon from Adventist uh Andrews
University.
This is going to take a bit, but it's
necessary before we examine the pioneers
because it will give us a good
background regarding development,
especially for those who are unaware,
and show us where they claim to be. Now,
we heard in that clip earlier, Ted used
all the right buzzwords. We believe in
three persons, co co-eternal, uh, the
trinity.
This examination will show us what they
mean by those words before then jumping
into the pioneers, which is the roots.
Okay,
first notice what Mr. Moon admits. I'm
going to get a drink here real quick.
So from his book, The Trinity,
Understanding God's Love, His Plan of
Salvation, and Christian Relationships,
notice what he he says here. I want to
start by by looking at this.
More recently, talking about in SDA
history, a further question has arisen
with increasing urgency.
Was the pioneers belief about the
Godhead right or wrong?
As one line of reasoning goes,
either the pioneers were wrong and the
present church is right,
or the pioneers were right and the
present SDA church has apostatized from
biblical truth.
Thank you, Jerry, for the honest and
forthright admission
because that is very sound logical
reasoning because that's exactly
correct.
Until they are ready to denounce their
pioneers as heretics, this problem in
their movement will persist.
It will never happen though because to
do so would be to undermine the entire
foundation and the whole house of cards
falls down. So instead, we get a a
hybridized version of, well, we've
changed, but we still try and retain
some of these core things from the
pioneers because, well, they're the
things Ellen confirmed.
But this admission also verifies our
thesis statement
because if what Moon and modern SDA
theologians claim, which is that the
pioneers were wrong and the modern
movement is correct, then the inverse of
his conclusion is true.
The pioneers were apostates
who didn't believe biblical truth,
which would mean they weren't raised up
by God to do anything other than serve
as an example for us of what not to do.
This statement also shows that it is
obviously no secret within the
leadership ranks that the SDA pioneers
were not trinitarians.
But there we have it. Either the modern
day SDA church has apostatized
or the pioneers were wrong on this
issue. The present SDA position is
correct and the pioneers were apostate
heretics who had a false god.
Doesn't necessarily mean that the the
current organization is correct either.
I think they're both wrong. But his
syllogism is correct, which would mean
that no, God did not raise them up to
restore his church. Now, in his paper
titled The Quest for a Biblical Trinity,
something I've referenced I don't know
how many times, we also find some other
pertinent uh scholarship. And the reason
we take the time to look at these
sources, folks, instead of me just
instead of me just saying it, is because
Adventists will try and tell you, "Oh,
he doesn't know what he's talking about.
I make stuff up. I misrepresent them."
All these sorts of excuses.
This paper is available in the
description box down below for those
that want to follow along. Okay, open up
the description box. There's the link
there. Bring it on up. The page numbers
will be on the screen for you. You can
follow along and see for yourself.
Check my homework. See if I'm twisting
things. I'm taking stuff out of context.
All these sorts of excuses. Don't just
take my word for it.
In this paper, he lays out the
historical track record of the SDA
church's position on the Godhead and how
it evolved over time. He opens the paper
with this paragraph.
Quote,
"In 1846, James White dismissed the
traditional doctrine of the Trinity
as the old unscriptural trinitarian
creed."
A century later at the 1946 world
session of the general conference of 7th
Day Adventists, the denomination that
James White co-founded voted official
endorsement of a fundamental belief
statement that explicitly professed
belief in the Trinity, quote unquote.
During the 60 years that have passed
since that action, a trinitarian view of
God has remained dominant amongst 7th
Day Adventists. Despite the general
awareness since uh Roy Gaines master's
thesis in 1963 that most of the earliest
Adventist leaders
were non trinitarians.
Close quote.
So as I mentioned their scholars will
tell you outright the pioneers were not
trinitarians but staunchly stood against
trinitarianism.
Some of them such as moon try to say
well a lot of them reformed in this area
and came around because of deeper
biblical study. This is not true as we
will see.
But I also want you to notice the
wording.
He says, "During the 60 years that
passed since the endorsement of the
heavenly trio in the fundamental
beliefs, a trinitarian view of God has
remained." And this is key, a
trinitarian view.
Because notice what he then goes on to
say.
In previous research, I have traced the
development of the Adventist doctrine of
God from opposition to the Trinity
doctrine as traditionally formulated
to acceptance of the biblical concept of
one God in three persons. I have also
traced the clear progression of in Ellen
White's visions from 1850 onward,
showing that her visions gradually
formed her concept of God until by 1898
when she published Desire of Ages, she
held a trinitarian concept.
So catch that.
He recognizes that the Adventist view of
God developed over time.
So God raised up people who rejected who
he is to restore his church and
gradually gave them more light as to who
it even is that they're worshiping and
preaching throughout the world.
Apparently Ellen was given progressive
revelation around this area and was
developing in her own understanding of
who God actually is. Despite the fact
that the church has known who God is for
2,000 years,
yet her earlier statements regarding God
are just as authoritative and divinely
inspired as the later ones, despite the
contradictions they'll create. This is
not a good track record uh track record
for the supposed restorers of the
church, the church that never fell away,
by the way. But you'll notice again he
uses the language of a trinitarian
concept.
There are not multiple trinitarian
concepts. The trinity is very specific.
Get a different term like your heavenly
trio. Stop trying to say, "Well, it it's
kind of a trinity." You'll see in that
paper he tries to say, "Well, what Ellen
says, you can basically say it's the
trinity." No, the trinity is something
specific. You guys don't believe what
the what what trinitarians believe. So,
own that you have your own concept. You
guys think this is biblical, so own it.
Stop trying to use Christian language
when you don't mean the same thing that
Christians do. He contrasts what we
believe by calling it unbiblical. And he
does so by saying the pioneers rejected
the traditional formulated trinity
doctrine and came to the acceptance of a
biblical concept
which is just laughable because as we
just saw the traditional formulation of
the trinity is biblical.
were using certain do language with the
doctrine of the trinity to convey the
concept more clearly.
What he means here is what all of their
scholars do which is uh that what I
presented earlier is based on
aristoilian philosophy and not strictly
on scripture. So therefore it's not
biblical. But notice what he also says.
The purpose of the present article is to
clarify more fully the similarities and
differences between Ellen White's view
of the heavenly trio and the traditional
doctrine of the trinity
in order to discover her position in
relation to the current debate amongst
Adventists.
Folks right there very clearly the
heavenly trio is not the trinity.
He keeps putting in front of it the word
traditional which is going to trigger a
bunch of SDAs to think, "Oh, see it has
no biblical basis. It's tradition." Not
even understanding
it. Just all tradition is not bad. Not
just that, but Adventists are full of of
tradition. Adventism is a tradition.
This idea that you have no tradition is
the evidence that you're a slave to
tradition.
But very clearly, the heavenly trio is
contrasted from the Trinity.
You don't get to just come along at a
later point and take a term, redefine
it, and then insist, "No, no, we're
trinitarians just like you, brother."
That's not how this works. The Trinity
is a specific term that refers to
something specific, like I laid out
earlier.
This is just more SDA word games and
slipperiness to try and make it seem
like they believe like Christians do,
but very clearly they mean something
different. There's no need for them to
use the word trinity. Trinity doesn't
just mean, well, three persons.
No, that's partial truth. That's like
Satan in the in the Garden of Eden.
Partial truth.
No, you guys need to just own Well, no.
We completely reject the Trinity because
we believe in a heavenly trio.
These three persons who are distinct
beings. Wait till we see f. Wait till
you see folks what we're going to get
into and you'll see what I'm talking
about by that.
But this is just more SDA word games and
slipperiness to try and make it seem
like they believe like we do when they
clearly mean something different. Their
prophetus was apparently inspired by
God,
the God she didn't actually know and was
his mouthpiece for years and years and
years, but was still trying to figure
out who he even was. Yeah, not looking
good so far. Now, notice what he says.
The concept of God that is explicit in
her later writings portrays the father,
son, and holy spirit as three eternal
persons of intellect, will and emotions
who are united in character, purpose,
and love.
There is no conflict among them, no
working across purposes, no competition,
not even disagreement. Thus, they are
not three gods as in polytheism or
tritheism, but one.
Furthermore, their unity is not a
mathematical paradox, but a rational
unity analogous to the unity seen in a
good marriage where husband and wife are
united in an everrowing oneness, but
without negating their individuality.
Close quote. So, what makes the heavenly
trio one god? Supposedly,
they aren't working at cross purposes.
That's why I said what I did earlier
using the Greek pantheon as an example.
Apparently, if Zeus and Neptune and all
the other gods of the Greek pantheon
gods weren't fighting for dominance, but
united on a mission, that would all of a
sudden make them one God.
That is not at all what Christians
believe. Folks, God is one singular
being.
The various gods of polytheistic
religions are all distinct persons and
beings.
And that last sentence, by mathematical
paradox, he is referring to the
Christian position, the one and the
many.
That God is three persons but one being.
Instead, they are one in rel re uh
relation like a marriage. The adventist
God is. Except no, you have two persons,
two beings in a marriage. This is the
classic taking something from creation
and trying to import that onto God and
his nature.
But notice the little footnote number 13
that he that he included on there as a
citation.
The fact that scripture has much to say
about the relational unity of God does
not preclude God's ontological unity.
But the ontological unity is certainly
less explicit in scripture.
So he calls this a mathematical paradox
and says the heavenly trio is not united
in this way but then says well they are
but scripture is certainly less
explicit.
Okay.
Is it really that shocking that this
movement is a confused mess on a
foundational issue like this trying to
reinvent the wheel? This is what happens
when you're full of pride and you think,
"Well, everyone was wrong before we came
along."
Now, notice how they defined the term
person because this is key. He pointed
out earlier that Ellen White supposedly
claimed that the father, son, and spirit
are three eternal persons of intellect,
will, etc. To which SDAs are going to
say, "See, we're trinitarians like Ted
did." But notice what they mean by the
term person.
He continues, quote, "James White
certainly did not doubt that God is
spirit." John 4:24.
But he insisted that though spiritual
beings, Christ and the Father are never
nevertheless divine persons who have a
literal tangible existence.
They are neither unreal nor imaginary.
The trinitarian creeds he knew of made
God so abstract, theoretical, and
impersonal that God was no longer
perceived as a real, caring, loving
being.
Close quote.
So by person, they mean you have a
literal tangible existence.
meaning they have physical bodies by
nature.
James White certainly believe that God
is spirit,
but because that doesn't make sense in
their physicalist worldview, they just
disregard that and say God God by nature
has a physical form.
Not simply that he has the ability to
manifest in physical form to interact
with creation,
but that by nature
God has an eternal physical tangible
body,
which would mean the father's physical
body has eternally existed even though
physical matter isn't eternal. That's
getting into like Mormonism.
But notice how in their view, if
something isn't able to be distilled
down into their simple way of thinking,
it must be imaginary.
Oh, I know Jesus says in Luke 24 that
spirits don't have flesh and bone. I
know that scripture says God is
everywhere,
but we're still going to say God is a
physical, tangible being because that's
the only thing that makes sense to us, a
bunch of 19th century heretics who
thought they were smarter than everyone
else.
But folks, the the Bible uses all sorts
of imagery to describe God.
It isn't all to be taken literally every
time. We just looked earlier. Does God
have wings and feathers?
Is he an eagle?
Jesus says he's the door. He's the vine.
this sort of like literalistic
reductionism of the pioneers and their
inability to understand what they were
reading whether it be the Bible or even
the Nicing Creed that is the root of the
issues. These people had no clue what
they were talking about. And the SDA
church has their whole thing around, you
know, they have to have this big idea
around, well, the Bible's just simple.
It's written for the common man. There's
a deeper root behind all of that. It's
not just them saying that. It's because,
well, they have to have that because
their pioneers were those types of
people. William Miller was that type of
person. So everything has to be this
real. It's it it just got over
complicated by those, you know, Roman
Catholics that confused everyone. It's
that sort of thing that's going on
there.
But notice James White associated the
Trinity as abstract and imaginary.
And because he personally felt that way,
that makes it so. Totally bad reasoning.
But with this definition of person in
mind,
now look at what Jerry Moon says
regarding Ellen's supposed vision where
she talks to Jesus.
Quoting from her vision,
quote, I have often seen the lovely
Jesus that he is a person.
I asked him if his father was a person
and had a form like himself.
said Jesus, I am in the express image of
my father's person.
Thus, her visions confirmed what her
husband had written in 1846,
that the father and the son are two
distinct, literal, tangible persons.
The visions also disproved to her mind
the claim of the Methodist creed that
God is without body or parts. Thus,
these early visions steered her
developing view of God away from credle
trinitarianism,
though they offered nothing directly
contrary to her later statements of what
I have called biblical trinitarianism.
Close quote.
Again, when they say person, they mean
tangible, literal, physical forms.
And Jesus has the identical form as God
the Father. There are two of those.
And notice what influenced her theology.
Scripture.
No. No visions.
It all goes back to visions.
That's the ultimate deciding factor in
the development of this system of
theology and the understanding of God.
Theology proverb. Theo meaning God.
ology, you know, the study of God, what
God supposedly revealed to Ellen as the
stamp of approval.
We also see a lack of understanding
regarding the Ning Creed, stating that
God is without parts and and body.
The these pioneers
thought that that that meant he's
imaginary and not real. Again, the
physicalist worldview completely
clouding the ability to understand
because no, that's not what the creed is
saying. Notice what RC Sproul says
regarding this phrase. This is in his
exposition of the Westminster confession
of faith which affirms the Ning creed.
So commenting on the phrase God is
without parts that part of the creed
what is it saying?
Quote
this is one way to affirm what is called
the simplicity of God.
God is a simple being rather than a
complex being who can be divided into
parts.
A human being, for example, is a complex
being with a head, ears, eyes, a nose,
arms, feet, and various organs,
parts.
When we seek to understand God, we tend
to project our human complexity onto his
being.
We list his attributes, immutability,
eternality, omniscience, omnipresence,
holiness, and others.
We tend to think that God is made up of
one part holiness, one part
immutability, one part omnipresence, and
several other parts.
But all of God
is all of his attributes in their
entirety.
Close quote.
Folks, without parts in the creed has to
do with God being indivisible.
He is who he is. He's not 25% love, 10%
just, 5% omnipotent, etc. That's what
the creed is laying out. But these
ignorant pioneers that damned everyone
else to predition and claimed were
confused
were themselves confused and thought it
was uh it was talking about God being a
disembodied imaginary creature because
he doesn't have ears and a nose and he's
not like 50%, you know, love and 20%
just, etc.
But because the SDA movement rejects
divine simplicity and claims it's a
Greek philosophical construct, they end
up even further off in the weeds,
espousing a triistic monarchian view
that's like a blend of polytheism with
three gods, but the father alone is the
Almighty. This is so silly. Just because
God doesn't ontologically have a body
doesn't mean he's not real.
Again, this just assumes their
physicalist worldview. Because now
notice what Moon goes on to say
regarding their prophetess's
understanding of the Holy Spirit
developing over time.
Quote, in the 19 or in the 1890s,
1890s,
oh, sorry, I got the wrong slide here.
Oh, I don't have this slide. Excuse me,
folks. In that case, I will just read it
to y'all. Sorry about that.
In the 1890s, when she became convinced
of the individuality and personhood of
the Holy Spirit, she referred to the
Holy Spirit in literal and tangible
terms, much like those she had used in
1850 to describe the Father and the Son.
close quote. That's on page 150 of that
paper in the desri- the description box
if you want to check that out.
But this means that prior to the 1890s,
all the supposed revelation she received
from the one true God didn't involve
understanding that the Holy Spirit is a
conscious person.
Yet the Holy Spirit, who is the
Almighty, is the one that inspired her
supposedly.
But not until the 1890s, folks. That's
30 years past their incorporation date
of 1863.
You didn't just say that the Holy Spirit
also has a tangible literal form. But
notice,
the Lord instructed us that this was the
place in which we should locate. We have
had every reason to think that we are in
the right place. We've been brought
together as a school and need to realize
that the Holy Spirit who is as much a
person as God is a person. Remember how
they define person is walking through
these grounds unseen by human eyes. That
the Lord God is our keeper and helper.
He hears every word we utter and knows
every thought of the mind. Close quote.
That's from manuscript 86 in 1899
speaking about the Battle Creek campus.
But get that folks.
They rejected the Ning Creed because it
made God seem imaginary or unreal. But
the Holy Spirit has a physical tangible
form and walks around but is invisible.
Get that? Physical matter but invisible.
Walking around on the earth. Yeah. But
it's Christians that supposedly have an
imaginary view of God because we don't
think he by nature has a physical body
from eternity past.
The Holy Spirit's walking around. The
Holy Spirit has legs
and is walking around but invisible.
Yeah. Which one of us sounds like they
have an imaginary friend? When they use
the term person, understand that's what
they mean. It is not what Christians
mean. It's that there are three tangible
forms. The father and the son looking
identical. And all three of those
persons slashbeings.
The term is used interchangeably are one
God because they're united in a mission
like we looked at on that chart.
But finally, Mr. Moon concludes with
this.
The change from Adventist rejection of
the traditional doctrine of the trinity
to acceptance of a biblical trinitarian
doctrine was not a simple reversal.
When James White denounced creedal
trinitarianism in 1846, Ellen White
agreed with both his positive point that
the father and the son are two distinct
literal tangible persons and his
negative point that the philosophical
trinitarianism held by by many did
spiritualize away the personal
reality of the father and the son.
Soon after this, she added the
conviction based on visions
that both Christ and the Father have
bodily form, rejecting the teaching of
one trinitarian creed that God is
without body or parts. Close quote.
So on top of all of the other issues,
where does he say this development came
from?
That's right, visions.
Just like Ellen asserted earlier, not
scripture.
Their stamp of approval on the correct
understanding in all of this came from
visions, not the Bible. They can huff
and puff all they want, but it doesn't
change the facts.
J just like all the other beliefs, James
came to this belief around God having a
physical body by nature. Not just that
Jesus added unto himself a human nature
at a point in time, but that God
eternally
It's not just that Jesus added unto
himself a human nature at a point in
time, but that God eternally
possesses a physical body. All three,
Father, Son, Spirit.
Ellen then has a vision that confirms
this where she talked face tof face with
Jesus.
She had an HR meeting up in heaven in
the temple
and Jesus confirmed to her that not only
does the father have a physical body,
but it's identical to that of Jesus's.
This is then used as the stamp of
approval from God that James was correct
on his position.
That's what they mean by, oh no, it's
all from Bible study. James was
studying, came to some conclusion or
some other pioneer studying and comes to
a conclusion. Ellen conveniently has a
vision and that confirms, oh yeah,
you're correct in your understanding.
So, it's just biblical.
Yeah.
And then they'll read off their script,
their their script of proof text, and
claim it's biblical because they have
some verse they can point to. But
ultimately it's because Ellen had a
vision and that's the ultimate thing
that cementss the idea in.
She's like the magic the the magic
eightball for the pioneers.
But what I wanted us to gain from that
before looking at the pioneers was to
showcase a couple things.
Here's a recap.
One,
SDA scholarship clearly recognizes and
admits that the pioneers were
anti-trinitarians,
but now the claim is, "No, no, no, we've
reformed. We've changed. We officially
believe in the Trinity." Now
two,
no, their current position is a hybrid
position between tritheism and
monarchianism where you have three
beings that are all God,
the father alone being the almighty and
what makes them one is a mission where
they work as a team to try and bring a
plan of salvation about.
Three, they do not mean the same thing
by the terms person and being that
Christians do and will claim that's
Greek philosophy and just dismiss it
even though the substance of what's
being said is biblical like we looked
at.
For their gods all have a physical
tangible form and walk around like a
man, but the Holy Spirit and the Father
are invisible to the mortal eye.
And then five, they have stolen the word
trinity to try and sound like
Christians, but very clearly they have
their own flavor or version of the
Trinity. A concept. That's what Jerry
Moon used, a concept of the Trinity,
but they believe and think that what
Christians believe is unbiblical.
Yet lots of SDAs will deny this, even
though Moon very plainly said they
reject what Christians believe.
traditional creedal trinitarianism which
is based on scripture and they claim
it's unbiblical and that the SDA church
has a biblical view of the trinity aka
the heavenly trio. They are not
trinitarians. They need to stop lying
and saying that they are and own up that
they are heavenly trioists.
totally different concept in idol that's
not real
and it's based on the vain imaginings of
a woman in the 19th century that thinks
she talked to Jesus face to face in
vision but Jerry Moon's paper clearly
settles our thesis for the night but now
despite that let's begin our exam of the
pioneers and why people like Jerry Moon
have sought to distance themselves from
them
but why the anti-heavenly trio folks in
their ranks want to see their movement
return to the pioneers,
the folks who think the SDA movement has
been infiltrated by Jesuits that were
that that planted the Trinity in the SDA
church. Okay,
first up,
JN Andrews,
the man for whom Adventist uh uh Andrews
University is named after and where
Jerry Moon works.
Notice what he says.
quote
the doctrine of the trinity which was
established in the church by the council
of Nika AD 3:25
this doctrine destroys
the personality of God and his son Jesus
Christ our Lord remember what they mean
by that phrase
the personhood or personality
the infamous measures by which it was
forced upon the church which appear upon
the pages of ecclesiastical history
might well cause every believer in that
doctrine to blush.
Close quote.
No, it wasn't established at Nika. Sir,
this is the problem yet again with these
pioneers. They had no clue what they
were criticizing. Nika was where an
official statement was put forth and the
Aryan heresy specifically was denounced.
You think it just arose in the 4th
century? It just like bam. It just
totally ridiculous, dude. It's literally
built. I mean, we can go back and look
at Ignatius has early early early. We're
talking about an individual who knew the
apostles.
It's like looking back through history
from where you're currently at and just
missing and dismissing so many things
and acting like, "Oh, it just arose in
the the fourth century."
Nika was where an official statement was
put forth and aranism was denounced. It
was the result of christoologgical
heresies that the church was already
dealing with prior to Nika that resulted
in the church having to formally lay out
what biblical orthodoxy actually is on
this subject.
Which makes complete sense because even
in the days of the apostles, folks, it's
in scripture. You already had
christoologgical heretics creeping in.
read the epistle to uh First John,
you already had Gnostic heretics
creeping in that were like, we had a
variety of views under the Gnostic
umbrella. Jesus isn't really a human.
He's a projection of light from heaven.
Kind of like the rays of of light from
the sun are. They're a projection from
the sun, but they're not really like he
doesn't have a physical actual corporeal
form because the physical matter is
tainted. These are the sort of things
the gnostics were saying. This was
around during the days of the apostles.
It makes perfect sense that God would
then lead his church in denouncing such
heresies and silencing them, which is
which is exactly what happened. Nothing
to do with it being forced. This is a
lack of understanding real church
history striking again.
And notice the Bible is clear. There is
only one Lord, the Almighty. We looked
at that. So he calls Jesus Jesus Christ
our Lord which would mean the father is
not Lord the Almighty and Jesus is some
he either Jesus is the Lord the almighty
and the father's not
or Jesus is some lesser lord like you
see Sarah calling Abraham
there's no other way that his statement
could be understood because he's
rejecting nyine creedal trinitarianism
which says father son and spirit are the
one lord
Yet here he's calling Jesus Christ Lord
and the Bible says there's only one
Lord.
So either he has to be in in your in Jan
Andrews's case some lesser Lord
lowercase L or this guy just doesn't
understand the Bible. But then post the
SDA movement's incorporation after 1863
after what they want to be the forgotten
years 1844 to 63. He says this in their
church paper.
And as to the son of God, he would be
excluded also, for he had God for his
father and did some point at the
eternity of the past have beginning of
days.
So that if we use Paul's language in an
absolute sense, it would be impossible
to find but one being in the universe
and that is God the father who is
without father or mother or descent or
beginning of days or end of life. Close
quote. That is the review and herald
September 7 1869.
Ah, so Jesus who is Yahweh like we
looked at according to this guy had a
beginning.
Only the father is truly eternal. No
sir, Jesus is the first and the last,
the great I am the eternal God. This is
blasphemous heresy.
Now before moving on, remember what Ted
Wilson was warning us about in that
opening clip.
He said people are going to be messaging
his secretary and assistant after his
talk to ask uh why he was in favor of
the heavenly trio. His response
because he's convicted it's what the
Bible says. Remember that it's what the
Bible says. Now listen to what he went
on to say less than five minutes later.
Okay.
mission has always been a part of the
Seventh Day Adventist Church. The first
missionary to be sent from the church
was John Neans Andrews. One of the
finest biblical scholars the church has
ever produced. One of the finest
biblical scholars the church has ever
produced.
One of the finest biblical scholars the
church has ever produced.
He was also a general conference
president.
So after warning people
about anti-trinitar or anti-heavenly
trio people,
he praised Jay and Andrews as what?
One of the best biblical scholars their
church has ever produced.
He was an anti-trinitarian heretic
and you named one of your higher ed
institutions after him.
Gee, Ted, I wonder why you're going to
have people emailing you.
I wonder why you guys are so confused.
And I'm sure they emailed your assistant
and said the same thing. The God that
says Jesus had a beginning and only the
father is without be beginning of days
is your guys's best scholar to date.
Yet you just warned earlier about people
who reject the eternality of the father,
son, and spirit. My good riddance, man.
So JN Andrews,
heretic.
Now for Uriah Smith. This guy helps
systematize SDA theology. Him, James
White, and Joseph Bates primarily.
This is from the October 28, 1890 issue
of the Review and Herald. The same
decade Ellen White's visions corrected
error on the Holy Spirit all of a sudden
being a person. Now,
from under the heading that asks, is the
Holy Spirit a person?
Quote,
"Are we to understand that the Holy
Spirit is a person the same as the
Father and the Son? Some claim that it
is, others that it is not." That was the
question someone asked. Answer:
The terms Holy Ghost are a harsh and
repulsive translation. It should be Holy
Spirit. He haggon numa in every
instance.
This spirit is the spirit of God and the
spirit of Christ. The spirit being the
same whether it is spoken of as
pertaining to God or Christ. But
respecting the spirit, the Bible uses
expressions which cannot be harmonized
with the idea that it is a person like
the father and the son.
Rather, it is shown to be a divine
influence from them both. the medium
which represents their presence and by
which they have knowledge and power
through all the universe when not
personally present.
Close quote. He is paring Ellen White
which is the stamp of approval from God
that it has to be bib biblical. Notice
desire of ages page 669.
Quote, "The Holy Spirit is Christ's
representative, but divested of the
personality of humanity
and independent thereof."
Cumbered with humanity, Christ could not
be in every place personally. Therefore,
it was for their interest that he should
go to the Father and send the Spirit to
be his successor on earth. No one could
then have any advantage because of his
location or his personal contact with
Christ. By the spirit, the Savior would
be accessible to all. In this sense,
he would be nearer to them than if he
had not ascended on high. Close quote.
Remember, what do they mean by the term
person or personality
physical tangible form?
So the Holy Spirit is apparently
Christ's representative but without the
physical form.
He doesn't remember she said three
persons of of of intellect, will etc.
The Holy Spirit is that divested though
of all those things and is Christ's
representative in his absence.
And she claims that with with his
physical body, Jesus couldn't be
omnipresent, which is why the Holy
Spirit was supposedly sent so that
Christ would be with every believer
accessible to all.
Hey, Jerry Moon, you told us that the
God uh that was developed into the
Desire of Ages was the accurate
representation of the Adventist God.
Well, this does not jive with the idea
that the Holy Spirit has a physical
tangible form walking around on the
earth, but is invisible.
Yet your prophet has said both of those
statements are from God.
And just so we're clear, this is
precisely what the Adventist believe
fundamental beliefs book says. Also,
quote,
Jesus asserted his omnipresence with the
assurance, lo, I am with you always,
even to the end of the age. Matthew
28:20. And where two are gathered, where
two or three are gathered together in my
name, I am there in their midst. Matthew
18:20.
Although his divinity has the natural
ability of omnipresence,
the incarnate Christ has voluntarily
limited himself in this respect. He has
chosen to be omnipresent through the
ministry of the Holy Spirit. Close
quote.
When people like Jerry Moon say they
developed a biblical doctrine of the
Trinity over and against the unbiblical
philosophically rooted position that
Christians affirm, what he really means
is over time, Ellen White clearly didn't
know what she believed on the spirit and
and she was supposedly uh or she she
wasn't uh she didn't know who it was
that she was actually in contact with.
And since she claimed it all came from
God, they have to try and make it all
work. Which is precisely why you have a
a multiple camps in their movement
bickering back and forth with one
another one another pointing to the same
sources for their position.
But no, that's not what John 14 says.
Jesus does not refer to the Holy Spirit
as himself divested of a physical form.
The Holy Spirit is a person and he is
distinct in personages or personage from
both the father and the son. Jesus is
also not limited in his omnipresence due
to the incarnation. Now let me
demonstrate such okay from an article on
our website. You can check this out. If
you just go to our website and type in
any of the keywords you see in this
title or even anything in the body copy,
it will pop up and you can bring it up
yourself. But let's start down here at
Jesus Christ is the fullness of the
Godhead bodily.
You can type in any of this
and this article will pop right up. But
notice,
Jesus Christ is the fullness of the
Godhead bodily.
Contrary to LG White teaching that the
father is the fullness of the Godhead
bodily,
Jesus is both fully man and fully God.
What's called the hypothatic union. This
means that Jesus possesses all of the
divine attributes which includes
omnipresence.
Jesus did not limit his divine
attributes by incarnating. Proponents of
this sort of thinking thinking typically
assert this by misinterpreting uh
Philippians 26 through8 what's known as
the kinosis heresy.
This passage does not say that Jesus set
his divinity aside and chose to
incarnate, but rather that he added unto
himself a human nature by leaving his
heavenly abode, his rightful estate, and
he humbled himself as a servant by
subjecting himself to the law. Galatians
4:4
to redeem creation.
Jesus demonstrates his omnipresence
while incarnate to Nathaniel in John
1:48-9.
Philip called by Jesus to follow him
realized Jesus was who the law and the
prophets foretold of the Messiah. So he
thought or he sought out Nathaniel to
tell him. That's John 1:43-5.
Upon hearing this that ge about Jesus
the Messiah, Nathaniel asks if anything
good can come out of Nazareth because
he's in disbelief. That tells you a lot
about the city of Nazareth. He then
finds Jesus and asks him how Jesus knows
him and Jesus tells him he saw Nathaniel
under the fig tree.
Astonished, Nathaniel believes that
Jesus is the Messiah, King of Israel.
This astonishment is because Jesus
wasn't physically present when Nathaniel
was under the fig tree where Philip
found him.
Yet he was able to see Nathaniel while
not being physically present.
Jesus even says if this is what won him
over, he will see things far greater
than that. John 150.
Jesus didn't claim to just know where
Nathaniel was, which is omniscience, but
that he saw him.
One would have to be present where
someone or something is to see it.
Another example is in Mark 7
26-30
where Jesus drives the demon out of the
Sarapheneician woman's daughter. He
honors the woman's faith that Jesus was
capable and able to do so without being
physically present.
Jesus drives the demon out of the
woman's daughter. Mark 7:29.
He is the one doing the driving out of
the demon, not the Holy Spirit.
Yet, he wasn't physically present.
This shows that Jesus's incarnation did
not limit his divine attributes.
A third example, one of the strongest,
is the encounter that Jesus has with the
official in John 4:46-54.
The man begs Jesus to come and heal his
son. John 4:47.
Jesus then tells the man to go. His son
will live. John 4:50. The man then
leaves and along his journey home, his
servants meet him to let him know the
boy is living. John 4:51.
They tell the official that it was
yesterday
at 1 in the afternoon that the boy was
healed. John 4:52.
It was at that moment that the official
remembered that was the exact hour the
previous day that Jesus said to the or
that Jesus said that the boy would live.
John 4:53.
The man's journey was more than a day
away. Yet Jesus healed the boy at the
moment of his declaration without
physically being present to do so,
demonstrating his omnipresence despite
his human body being limited to space
and place.
It is Jesus doing these healings and
before the Holy Spirit is sent as
another helper in John 14:16-18.
Jesus would have to be present to do
these healings which means his
omnipresence was not diminished by
incarnating.
Scripture is clear that Jesus is
immutable and does not change. He is the
same today, yesterday, and forever.
Hebrews 13:8.
So, no, the Adventist Church has a
different Jesus and a different spirit.
Both of which Paul warns us to be on the
lookout for in 2 Corinthians 11 1-4. But
now, notice what else Uriah Smith says.
Quote, this is from looking on unto
Jesus page 10.
God alone is without beginning.
At the earliest epoch, when a be when a
beginning could be a period so remote
that to finite minds it's essentially
eternity appeared the word.
In the beginning was the word and the
word was with God and the word was God.
John 1:1.
This unccreated word was the being
who in the fullness of time was made
flesh and dwelt among us. His beginning
was not like that of any other being in
the universe.
It is set forth in the mysterious
expressions,
his God's only begotten son, John 3:16.
The only begotten of the father, John
1:14, and I proceeded forth and came
from God, John 8:42.
Thus it appears that by some divine
impulse or process, not creation, known
only to omniscience and possible only to
omnipotence,
the son of God appeared.
And then the Holy Spirit by an infirmity
of translation called the Holy Ghost.
Like he said earlier, the spirit of God,
the spirit of Christ, the divine uh
athletus and medium of their power
representative of them both. Psalm 139:7
was in existence also.
Close quote.
Wrong. Do not pass go directly to jail.
John 1:1 does not say that in the
beginning the word appeared.
And by the beginning,
John means a point so far in the the
distant past, it's basically eternity.
There's lots out there, folks, on the
grammar and construction of John 1:1 A,
B, and C. You can go check that out for
yourself from actual sound theologians
of various traditions. But catch the
confusion here.
Jesus wasn't created. No, no, no. He had
a beginning, though.
Known only to omniscience, the son of
God just appeared. But he wasn't
created, folks.
Such a mess.
But it's Christians that are confused.
Got it? He says, "At a point so far back
into the past, we can't even fathom it.
Jesus had a beginning." And that's what
John 1:1 is supposedly saying.
And he tries to use the word begotten to
support this. We will look at that with
regards to a different quote in a bit.
But no, that is not what the term
monogates means.
But here we plainly see the Holy Spirit
is the power and representative of both
the father and the son in their physical
absence. He is not a person.
And at this time, you had Ellen White
confirming this nonsense in visions,
which is what propagated it as
legitimate.
Then over time, as Jerry Moon pointed
out, there's new light and insights that
she receives that contradict previous
understandings, and it's just blanketed
over as present truth and new light from
God.
Total doctrinal mess. And it's just a
bunch of ancient heresies resurrected
claiming to be new insight from God and
claiming everyone else is clueless,
confused, in the dark. They've been
they've been swindled by Roman
Catholicism.
Yeah.
Again, same book, looking unto Jesus.
Quote,
"When Jesus left heaven to die for a
lost world, he left behind for the time
being his immortality also."
But how could that be laid aside?
That it was laid aside
or he could not have died.
But he did die as a whole, as a divine
being, as the son of God, not embody
only while the spirit, the divinity,
lived right on. For then the world would
have only a human savior, a human
sacrifice for its sins. But the prophet
says that his soul was made an offering
for sin. Isaiah 53:10.
Close quote.
Ah, the same Isaiah that told us Yahweh
alone created all things, that Yahweh
alone is the only savior, apparently
supports the idea that Jesus came into a
being or or had a beginning rather at a
point in the distant past is a distinct
being from the father. And when Jesus
died, both his humanity and his lesser
divine nature than the father also died.
But Christians are confused, folks.
Christians are the ones that are
confused.
But here we have a Jesus that isn't the
Jesus of Hebrews 13 that's the same
yesterday, today, and forever.
The Christian position can actually deal
with this
when you understand the hypothetic union
that the divine person of the word added
unto himself a human nature. He didn't
set anything by divinity aside or or any
part of his divinity aside, but rather
added unto himself a human nature
such that he didn't actually change.
He's still immutable. There's no divine
attributes being set aside, being
limited, being turned off like a switch.
No, it doesn't work that way. This is
again where divine simplicity comes in.
God is who he is. There's no like, well,
Jesus is God, but he turned this off and
you know, he's not omnipresent fully now
and like this is breaking God into a
bunch of parts.
But we also clearly see
that Smith didn't understand the
hypothatic union.
the two natures of Christ in the single
person, which as we will see later, the
SDA church emphatically asserts they now
believe.
Instead, we get a Kosis type Jesus,
which we will look at more closely in a
in a different quote.
And yes, to make matters worse, this is
the same Uriah Smith that had this to
say regarding the atonement. And no, the
SDA church hasn't denounced this, to my
knowledge.
quote,
"The death of Christ and the atonement
are not the same thing."
And this relieves matter of all
difficulty.
Christ did not make atonement when he
shed his blood upon the cross. Let this
fact be fixed forever in your mind.
Close quote. Yeah. What I'm going to
have fixed forever in my mind is you are
a damnable heretic who has no clue what
the hell you're talking about. What a
blast. Only a demon would say something
like this. What a blasphemous statement.
Only a fool would say such a thing.
For a movement that wants to point at
everybody else and say, "They're all
confused. They're all lost." Yeah. Okay.
Let that fact forever be fixed in your
mind that the atonement and the death of
Christ are not the same thing. Wow.
When Christ shed his holy blood on the
cross, he didn't atone for your sins.
That was only where the atoning
sacrifice took place. That's what they
teach.
And why is this the set in stone
understanding?
Because of Uriah Smith? Of course not.
It's what Ellen White claimed to be
shown in vision, which is their stamp of
approval from God, that they were
understanding everything correctly. The
infamous Ellen White, Patriarchs and
Prophets, page 357. Quote,
"The blood of Christ, while it was to
release the repentant sinner from the
condemnation of the law, was not to
cancel the sin. It would stand on record
in the sanctuary until the final
atonement. So in the type, the blood of
the sin offering removed the sins from
the penitent and it rested in the
sanctuary until the day of atonement."
Close quote.
This is wicked demonic doctrine. Period.
And no, as we've looked at many times,
the sins of penitent people were not
transferred in type by the blood of the
sacrificed animals into the sanctuary to
be stored until the day of atonement,
which is what she also claimed in the
same book.
Notice again another article from our
website.
Did the high priest carry the blood of
sacrificed animals into the holy place
every day
in patriarchs and prophets as well as
elsewhere? Ellen White falsely asserted
that during
the daily ministration of the priests in
the holy place,
the blood of the sacrificed animals was
carried by the priest into the holy
place and sprinkled before the veil. and
that by this ceremony the sin was
through the blood transferred in figure
to the sanctuary.
This contradicts the Bible where we are
told that apart from the once a year day
of atonement service, the priest only
sprinkled blood before the veil in the
holy place, meaning taking the blood
into the holy place on two occasions.
when the priest sinned, Leviticus 4
3-12, and when the entire Israelite
community sinned, Levitic Leviticus
4:13-21.
Blood was never taken into the holy
place on a daily basis when one of the
leaders sinned, Leviticus 4:22-26,
nor when an individual sinned.
Ellen White had no clue what she was
talking about.
So no, yet again, she contradicts
scripture and the light from the lesser
light contradicts the greater light.
So all of that to say, Uriah Smith,
heretic,
James White, husband to the prophetus
and another key player in systematizing
SDA theology. First, notice what he says
in the February 7, 1856 issue of the
organization's paper, the Review and
Herald.
Quote,
"The mystery of iniquity began to work
in the church in the in in uh in Paul's
day. It finally crowded out the
simplicity of the gospel and corrupted
the doctrine of Christ, and the church
went into the wilderness. Martin Luther
and other reformers arose in the
strength of God and with the word and
spirit made mighty strides in the
reformation. The greatest fault we can
find in the reformation is the reformers
stopped reforming.
Had they gone on and onward till they
had left the last vestage of papacy
behind such as natural immortality
sprinkling the trinity and Sunday
keeping the church would now be free
from her unscriptural
errors. Close quote.
So, like we saw last week with Ted
Wilson, we see the claim that the
Christian church apparently went
apostate immediately after the apostles
and beginning with Martin Luther, the
Reformation was the beginnings of what
would lead to a restoration,
the SDA church being the fullness of
that restoration supposedly. No, folks,
that's not what was going on there. But
we even hear the Anabaptist claim. The
problem with the reformers is they
stopped reforming,
aka they believe things the SDA pioneers
claim aren't biblical, so therefore
they're not.
The reason Luther didn't go on to reject
the things that James White listed are
because they're biblical.
Those aren't things that aren't pro
those are those things are not
problematic.
But amongst that he lists the trinity of
which he erently claims is a Roman
Catholic popish invention.
Hey James, then why does the Eastern
Church also universally affirm the
trinity or should I say the Eastern
churches?
These pioneers folks had zero concept of
the Eastern uh branch of the church,
which honestly as far as they were
concerned, they were probably like, "Oh
yeah, those people aren't even
Christians." Yeah, it wasn't Roman
Catholicism that corrupted the doctrine
of Christ.
I'm reformed, so obviously I have my
theological differences with Rome, but
what a joke.
Once again, we have an SDA pioneer
faulting Rome for the very thing they
themselves are guilty of. It never ends.
The SDA church loves to claim that
they're true heirs of the Reformation
because they're the only ones that kept
reforming. But what that really means is
they're a mess of a bunch of various
theological heresies as well as various
contradictions because they're not they
weren't integrative thinkers.
The reformation didn't even begin with
Luther.
Ellen would go on to write the great
controversy uh uh uh
after this quote,
but she tried starting with the
Waldenzians,
but it didn't start there either. I
talked about this a little bit last
week. St. Francis of Aisi, for example.
Now, you're going to get Rome claiming
that, well, St. Francis didn't exit out
of fellowship with the Pope and and and
rebel against the Pope, etc. But the the
point being is is pointing to Luther as
like, oh, it started there. It's like,
well, that's just that's not really
true. That's kind of a caricature of
history.
But St. Francis of Aisi well before the
Waldensians.
He was seeking to to reform like the
decadence of the church more in
accordance with like the poverty and
simple life of Christ. But nevertheless,
we have another pioneer of this movement
that doesn't know history claims the
trinity is a Roman Catholic invention
and rejected something he didn't even
understand.
Now notice this quote.
And this says a lot about where their
movement is today and why they have
Aryan heretics in their ranks.
quote, "In the divine law and in the
gospel of the divi, the the divine son
are the tests of Christian character.
And it is with an ill grace that those
who have been splitting up into petty
sex during the 19th century, that's
rich, calling other groups sex when
they're a sect."
splitting up into petty sex during the
19th century over forms of church
government, matters of expediency, free
and restricted salvation, trinity and
unity, whether we may sing any good hymn
in church, or only the Psalms of David,
and other matters which constitute no
test of fitness for heaven, now pounce
upon us and display any amount of
religious horror, simply because we
regard strict conformity to the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus. The only true test of Christian
character.
Close quote. October 12, 1846 issue of
the Review and Herald.
So, get that. It doesn't matter if you
have a false god.
That's not a test of Christian
Orthodoxy.
Yet, he says strict conformity to the
Ten Commandments is. News flash, James.
If you don't believe in the trinity, you
have a false god and you violate all
four of the first commandments.
This evidences how these heretics just
up and deem themselves to be the new
arbittors of what makes you a Christian,
totally untethered from history,
radically unhinged. And when people try
and point to Luther, including Roman
Catholics, sorry Roman Catholic friends
in the audience, when they try to point
to Luther to say, "Oh, it's just this
novel thing. It's just such a caricature
of history.
But this is another area where they'll
claim the reformers did the same thing.
No, they didn't. Unlike James White, the
reformers had connection to the church
universal in history.
They weren't just rogue agents like
James White bouncing from one heretical
sect to the next
just up and deeming themselves, well,
we're God's people now.
This guy came from the Christian
Connection, folks. a restorationist
unitarian sect, then ended up in
Millerism, another sect. Then goes on to
help establish the SDAs, another sect.
Yeah, it's a real sound track record.
But also, the statement aged like milk
because here we are 170 years later. And
Adventists are one of the most
splintered, divided groups out there.
Like we looked at last week, Christians
are far more united than Adventists.
It's like if they only understood the
purpose of the creeds.
Oh, no, those aren't biblical. Yeah,
they are. So, now what's your excuse?
What what aspect of the creed is not
biblical? The apostles creed, the
athanation creed, the nying creed. What
what aspect of that's not biblical?
We are united on the gospel and who God
is, the foundations of the Christian
faith. Yeah, we disagree on some areas
of mechanics because believe it or not,
everything in theology is not just a
cakewalk.
Yeah, believe it or not, it's we're
we're talking about the most complex
aspects of all of reality.
Believe it or not, it's not all just
this idea of, oh, the Bible was written
in for the common man. Where are you
getting this?
Yes, some aspects are the general basics
for what a person needs to know to be
made right with God. But theology is
vast, man. Just silly to think such a
thing.
Adventists can't even agree on if it's
okay to eat chicken,
if going to the movie theater is okay,
what proper dress reform looks like, if
you can go to a restaurant on Saturdays
before the sun goes down, and literally
countless factions and splinters
depending on your geographical location.
Yet, they're the bastion of unity
amongst all of us, confused, deceived
Protestants and Catholics and Roman and
Eastern Orthodox.
Now, to the next quote. If you tuned in
last week when we broke the great
controversy chain, you're going to
notice where Ted Wilson got some of his
talking points from regarding Jude.
Quote,
"Beloved, when I have all diligence to
write unto you of the common salvation,
it was needful for me to write unto you
and exhort you that ye should earnestly
contend for the faith which was once
delivered unto the saints." Jude 3:4.
The exhortation to contend for the faith
delivered to the saints
is to us alone.
And it is very important for us to know
what for and how to contend. In the
fourth verse, he gives us the reason why
we should contend for the faith, a
particular faith. For there are certain
men or a certain class who deny the only
Lord God and our Lord Jesus Christ.
The way spiritualizers have disposed of
or denied the only Lord God and our Lord
Jesus Christ is first using the old
unscriptural trinitarian creed that
Jesus Christ is the eternal God.
Though they have not one passage to
support it, while we have plain
scripture testimony in abundance that he
is the son of the eternal God.
Close quote. Ah, so remember last week
Ted Wilson cited uh Jude 4 and said this
exact same thing.
See where he got it from? The faith once
for all delivered to the saints is what
the SDA church is heralding. and that
alone.
Again, notice his distinction between
the God uh uh God the Father as Lord
and Jesus as Lord Jesus Christ.
If you're not a trinitarian, which this
fellow was not, then you have two lords
when scripture says no, there's one
lord, which circles us right back to
having to say Jesus is some lesser
lowercase lord like an earthly king,
which is precisely what this guy taught.
As you can see, he claimed Jesus is not
the eternal God.
This is also the quote Jerry Moon
referenced in his paper. The old
unscriptural Nying creed can't be
supported with one passage of scripture
supposedly
demonstrating that Jesus is the eternal
God. Moon claims that James White would
go on to reform on this. No,
he didn't, as we will see momentarily.
But how ironic. Jesus isn't the eternal
God, he says. And he cites Jude 3 and4
which he talks about the faith once for
all delivered to the saints and that
Jude exhorts defending the true Christ.
Well, had he bothered to think before
writing such a blasphemous statement, he
would have seen that Jude says regarding
the Lord Jesus Christ in verse 5, what
he what's he say?
That Jesus led Israel out of slavery in
Egypt. That's Jude 5. So after
establishing there is a faith that was
deposited by the apostles.
That's what they were contending for.
There are people who have crept in
trying to lead people after a different
Jesus.
He then goes on to give examples of the
true Jesus. And in Jude 5, he says,
"This Jesus that we believe in led our
forefathers out of the wilderness."
Jude begins to describe the deeds of the
true Christ to identify the true one.
Well, what does Deuteronomy 5:15 say
regarding who led Israel out of slavery
in Egypt? This is the fourth commandment
ironically in the second giving of the
law.
Quote,
"You shall remember that you were a
slave in the land of Egypt,
and the Lord your God brought you out
from there with a mighty hand and with
an outstretched arm. Therefore, the
Lord, the Lord your God, commanded you
to keep the Sabbath day.
Ah, so the Almighty did this work. The
Lord God, Yahweh, Jehovah, not some
lesser Lord, which means which means
Jude believed that Jesus is the
Almighty, the eternal God. Which means
James White had no clue what he was
talking about and was a heretic that
believed in a false god. But now notice
what he went on to say a mere six years
later in the review and herald.
Quote, "To assert that the sayings of
the of the son and his apostles are the
commandments of the father
is as wide from the truth
as the old trinitarian absurdity that
Jesus Christ is the very and eternal
God." What a blaspheming heretic.
Just even reading such just makes me
And as the faith of Jesus embraces every
requirement peculiar to the gospel, it
necessarily follows that the
commandments of God mentioned by the
third angel embrace only the 10 precepts
of the father's immutable law,
which are not peculiar to any one
dispensation, but common to all. Close
quote.
So, not only does he blasphemously uh
blasphemously claim Jesus isn't the
eternal God, but he says that Jesus
didn't give the Ten Commandments to
Israel. Only the Father did. It was his
the father's immutable law.
Uh no, James, like we just saw, Jude 5
says Jesus led Israel out of slavery in
Egypt.
When we look at Deuteronomy 5, where
this is documented regarding the second
giving of the law, Jesus is the one that
was giving the commands.
James relegates that distinctly to the
father alone. He alone is the lawgiver.
No, it was the one true God that did
this. Father, son, and spirit.
Once again, the issue is their inability
to recognize that God is not like them.
He's not a man. He's not like anything
in creation.
That's why the incarnation is such a
beautiful thing.
It is God condescending down to us.
They fashioned a god in their own image
to their own shame and tried reinventing
the wheel which only led to confusion
and resurrection of a bunch of ancient
heresies.
But notice, why is James saying stuff
like this? Is it because scripture says
the father alone gave the law?
No, as we just saw, Jude recognized
Jesus was the almighty God that gave
Israel the law and led them out of
bondage. It is, of course, because of
his wife, the prophetus. This is
supposedly the divine stamp of approval
from God that the father alone gave the
law.
Quote, the son of God was next in
authority to the great lawgiver.
He knew that his life alone could be
sufficient to ransom fallen man. He was
of as much more value than man as his
noble spotless character and exalted
office as commander of all the heavenly
host were above the work of man. He was
in the express image of his father not
in features alone but in perfection of
character. Close quote. Remember what we
read earlier from Jerry Moon.
Ah, there it is. Remember, it's not from
scripture. It's from visions. She was
given better clarification from visions.
Yeah.
So, after the fall of man,
this is what Ellen claims she was shown
regarding Jesus in heaven and what led
to him then proposing a plan to the
father that took three tries for the
father to be convinced in a council
meeting. We've looked at this before,
but notice she distinguishes Jesus from
the great lawgiver, the father.
Jesus has an exalted status that was
conferred on him by the father. We also
see that she claims the father has a
physical body ontologically.
Jesus does as well. Again, their
physicalist worldview clouding the
picture. But regarding this exalted
status,
testimonies for the church, volume
eight.
Quote,
God is the father of Christ. Christ is
the son of God. To Christ has been given
an exalted position.
He has been made equal with the father.
All the councils of God are opened to
his son. Close quote.
The fact that they will insult your
intelligence by telling you this
actually means Jesus is co-equal and
co-eternal with the father and the
spirit that they affirm the trinity is
such a joke. It does not get any clearer
than this.
Go look at the source, folks. Adventists
are going to try and tell you that's out
of context, and they're just going to
move along. Yeah. Okay.
No, you're either dishonest or ignorant
of your system. You haven't studied well
enough.
Yahweh was not exalted to be made equal
with Yahweh.
No councils had to be opened up to
Jesus.
This is the same garbage that's found in
the Mormon plan of salvation,
which Ellen more closely resembles and
stole from very clearly. This is exactly
what happened in their pre-earth origin
story. There were special councils that
were open to Jesus, who they both claim
is Michael the Archangel, and this made
Lucifer jealous, and he rebelled because
he wasn't allowed to be brought into
these councils.
We're going to look at that more later
when we get to Ellen White. But
nevertheless, this is a false Christ.
This is not the Jesus of scripture.
Matthew 24:24, 2 Corinthians, uh, 11
1-4. This is not the God of the Bible.
They can try and use whatever language
they want. They can assert, "Oh, we're
trinitarians till they're blue in the
face." It does not change the facts.
They are stuck having to affirm and
uphold these quotes. And because this is
their ultimate commitment, they will do
and say whatever they have to in order
to defend Ellen White.
But now notice in 1881,
the year that James White died,
literally the year that he died, folks,
review and Herald, January 4, 1881.
Can we get any later in his life when we
talk about oh he reformed
quote
in his exaltation
before
before before
he humbled himself to the work of
redeeming lost sinners. Meaning you
can't point to postincarnation
exaltation of Jesus the man
to claim that's what Ellen was talking
about. No, there was an exaltation
before he humbled himself to the work of
redeeming lost sinners.
Christ thought it not robbery to e to be
equal with God because in the work of
creation and the institution of law to
govern created intelligences, he was
equal with the father. Yes, after his
exaltation,
the father was greater than the son in
that he was first.
The son was equal with the father in
that he had received all things from the
father.
The reader may now look upon the father
and the son to use a common figure as a
great creating and law instituting firm.
Close quote.
So before Jesus incarnated, before folks
before the incarnation,
when scripture talks of Jesus being
exalted, it is talking about
postincarnation
as a man,
the only man to overcome death, to
redeem creation, to live accordance in
accordance with the law perfectly, etc.
It's not talking about before he
incarnated, there was this other
exaltation. That's what they're talking
about. And in that exaltation, he was
exalted to be made equal with the
father. Just like his wife claimed she
she was shown by God in the great
controversy narrative. And it's because
of this exaltation that one may look
upon the son and father both as a common
figure for creator and lawgiver. Even
though previously God revealed through
Ellen that Jesus was next in authority
to that great lawgiver.
And James was going around teaching it
was the father's immutable law, not
Jesus's.
But notice the father was greater than
the son because why?
He was first.
No, Mr. Moon. James White did not come
around to orthodoxy.
He didn't even come around to embrace
where you guys currently are either.
They love to point to this statement
from four years prior to try and support
this idea.
Quote,
"The inexplicable trinity that makes the
Godhead three in one and one in three,
what Jerry Moon called a mathematical
paradox is bad enough, but that ultra
unitarianism that makes Christ inferior
to the Father is worse." Did God say to
an inferior, "Let us make man in our
image." Close quote.
Folks, understand this statement in
light of the one we just read from four
years later. Four years later,
what does James White mean by Jesus not
being inferior? There was a point in the
past where Jesus came to be and was then
exalted to be made equal with the
father. And it's because of that
that they are not seen as inferior.
That's not in harmony with what Ted
Wilson said in that clip.
No, this is heresy.
This is not some secondary thing, folks.
If you do not believe in the triune God,
you're going to go to hell.
That's not me saying this. You have a
false god. You have a different God.
This isn't
like should there be drums and worship
music? Folks, if you don't believe in
the Trinity, you have a false god.
It's time to wake up. It's time to get
serious about this if you're an
Adventist.
It's not just picking at straws here,
folks. This is a serious matter.
At some point, you have to draw the
line. It's not just, oh, well, we
believe in the Ten Commandments. Who
gave the Ten Commandments? She didn't
even have the right lawgiver.
Jesus was never exalted to be made equal
with the father prior to the creation of
the earth to then be led into some
special council of God the Father and be
brought into the plan of creating the
earth.
When they cite stuff like this
like he like James White does here
regarding let us make man in our image.
Don't forget they don't believe heavens
and earth were created in the beginning
in Genesis.
That's only the earth and the firmament
of the earth. Heaven and the angels in
the universe existed long before the
earth.
Which is why people are often shocked to
hear this because they associate young
earth creationism with all of creation.
But no, the 7th adventist church is only
talking about the earth. And it was
prior to the creation of the earth that
Jesus was supposedly brought into
existence had a beginning but he's not
created
and it's so long ago in the past that
basically it seems like eternity. That's
what these pioneers were saying.
But as we saw he believed that Jesus had
a starting point and that's why the
father is greater. So, James White,
flaming heretic.
Hopefully, he repented of his damnable
heresy on his deathbed. Seriously,
blasphemous, flaming heresy.
Next up, Joseph Bates, the other key
player in systematizing SDA theology.
quote, "My parents were members of long
of longstanding in the congregational
church. With all of our converted
children thus far, and anxiously hoped
that we would also unite with them, but
they embrace some points in their faith
which I could not understand, I will
name two only. Their mode of baptism and
the doctrine of the Trinity."
Respecting the Trinity, I conclude that
it was an impossibility for me to
believe that the Lord Jesus Christ, the
son of the father, was also the almighty
God, the father, one in the same being.
I said to my father, if you can convince
me that we are one in the same sense,
that you are my father and I your son,
and also I am your father and you are my
son, then I can believe in the trinity.
Close quote.
fashioning a god in the likeness of man
that he deems to be worthy of belief
strikes again.
Oh, because he deemed it to be worthy.
Oh, okay. I can understand it. So
therefore,
he uses an analogy of two human beings
and then pushes that off onto how God
must be by nature. Despite God telling
us very clearly that he's not like
anything in creation, Isaiah 40, all
throughout the psalter, etc., God is not
like creation, he is wholly other.
This is also another example of why the
terms person and being are so important
in this discussion because once again,
we have another pioneer claiming he
couldn't believe that Jesus is the
almighty God because Jesus isn't the
father.
which should tell you that these folks
were not very bright theologians despite
the SDA church often lauding this man in
particular as an incredible theologian.
They'll go on and on about how he was a
sea captain and a rough and tough guy.
Yeah, don't care. His theology was
heretical,
but also it's rather riched that he
criticizes infant baptism as being
unbiblical when this is the movement
that makes you take vows to the SDA
organization, including to believe and
uphold the writings of Ellen White in
order to be baptized.
Yeah,
I can make a biblical defense for my
position on on infant baptism. They
can't for their baptismal vows to Ellen
White or any of them for that matter.
But another quote, bit of a long one
here in a letter he wrote to William
Miller.
Quote,
much derision is made about those of our
company that have joined the Shakers,
another cult from the 19th century. I
say it as a shame to them first to have
preached so clearly and distinctly the
speedy coming of of the Lord Jesus
Christ personally to gather his saints
and then to go and join the shakers in
their faith that he talking about Jesus
came spiritually in their mother Anne
Lee more than 70 years ago. This without
doubt in my mind is owing to their
previous teaching and belief of the
doctrine called the trinity.
How can you find fault with their faith
while you are teaching the very essence
of that never known never to be
understood doctrine
for their comfort and faith and of
course your own. You say Christ is God
and God is love. As you have given no
explanation, we take it to come from you
as a literal exposition of the word.
Close quote.
So, I guess God's not omnipotent because
that can't be fully comprehended in the
human brain. I guess God's not eternal
because we can't comprehend that in our
mind.
According to this silly standard, if man
can't totally wrap their head around it,
it can't be true. It's almost like
pragmatism in a sense. But there we go.
Yet again, Jesus isn't God. That's
relegated to the father. He continues,
"We believe that Peter and his master
settled this question beyond controversy
in Matthew 16:13-19.
And I cannot see why Daniel and John has
not fully confirmed that Christ is the
son and not God the Father."
How could Daniel explain his vision of
the seventh chapter if Christ was God?
Here he sees one like the son of man and
it cannot be proved that it had that it
was any other person.
He adds that in brackets
here. He sees one like the son of man,
and there was given him dominion and
glory and a kingdom by the ancient of
days. Then John describes one seated on
a throne with a book in his right hand.
And he distinctly saw Jesus come up to
the throne and take the book out of the
out of the hand of him that sat thereon.
Now if it is possible
now if it is possible to make these two
entirely different transactions appear
in one person
then I could believe that God died and
was buried instead of Jesus and that
Paul was mistaken when he said now the
God of peace that brought again from the
dead our Lord Jesus that great shepherd
of the sheep and that Jesus also did not
mean what he said when he asserted that
he came from God and was going to God
and much more if necessary to prove the
utter absurdity of such a faith. Close
quote.
My that the the amount of confusion the
amount of confusion.
So it's entirely absurd to believe that
Jesus is God. Once again, we have
another pioneer who doesn't even know
the basics but is criticizing the the
the Trinity as an absurdity.
I I can't believe Jesus is the father.
Trinitarians don't believe that, sir.
I can't believe Jesus and the father are
the same person. Trinitarians don't
believe that, goofball.
He basically says to believe Jesus is
God is to believe Jesus is the father.
So, he thought trinitarianism was
modalism.
Again, you guys don't know history. This
is like It's like we're literally just
taking a a walk.
It's like we're literally just taking a
walk through like the third and fourth
centuries again. Like dude, this was
dealt with like hundreds of years before
you guys were even around.
And here we heard the classic Jesus is
the son of God, not God.
This is why I was saying in the
beginning, understanding the economics
versus the ontology of the trinity is so
important. This is a prime example,
folks, for you right here of an
individual who didn't understand that.
Well, how could we how could it say how
could scripture say in some places God
raised Jesus from the dead if he is God?
Uh, I don't know. Maybe the same way
that Jesus himself said in John 2 and
John 10 that most assuredly and without
a question he would raise himself from
the dead, the scriptures also say the
spirit raised him from the dead. This
just proves trinitarianism.
A son is still the same ontologically as
their father.
So that just backfires on them. But he
talks of Daniel 7 in the ancient days
being approached by Christ. And this is
supposed to mean Jesus isn't God, he's
the son. Here we have an issue of not
just understanding the incar
misunderstanding the incarnation,
but the hypothatic union. Again, we'll
look at this more closely in a bit with
another quote, but this objection holds
zero water because it's based on just
not understanding the basics. It's like
these objections. It's like, dude,
people were around before you, Mr.
Bates. Christians were around before
you. I know you guys think that you were
some special selected, you know, you
guys are just better than everyone else.
You guys glow in the dark. You're so
special.
This was around long before you guys.
You don't think people understood and
read that he's the son of God? You don't
understand what you're talking about.
But anything to pawn everything off on
Roman Catholicism.
But at the same time, this was part of
who God supposedly raised up to restore
his church. All righty then. Joseph
Bates, heretic,
JN Lowber
from their church paper, September 20,
1898. Notice the date, folks.
1898.
It's almost the turn of the century.
They love to use the excuse that all the
christoologgical mess was cleaned up by
this point. Yeah, think again. Like
Jerry Moon did in his paper. Well, in
1890, you know, Ellen White finally came
around to understanding the Holy
Spirit's a person. Yet, you have this
guy
sent out to to parrot his ancient
heresies as some new light from God.
Under the heading the spirit of God in
this issue of the Review and Herald,
this is their church paper, folks.
The spirit of God is spoken of in
scriptures as God's representative. Ah,
like we saw in the fundamental beliefs
book, the power by which he works, the
agency by which all things are upheld.
This is clearly expressed by the
psalmist where he inquires, "Wither
shall I go from thy spirit? Or wheither
shall I flee from thy presence? If I
ascend unto heaven, thou art there? If I
make my bed in hell, behold, thou art
there. If I take the wings of the
morning and dwell in the uttermost parts
of the sea, even there shall thy hand
lead me, and thy right hand shall hold
me." Psalm 139:7-10.
We learn from this language that when we
speak of the spirit of God,
we are really speaking of his presence
and power. Close quote.
This is in 1898, folks.
The decade when Ellen White supposedly
corrected all this mess.
But if the spirit of God is just the
presence of God, why does he speak? If
the Holy Spirit's only a a power and
agency, not a distinct person from the
father and son, then why does the Holy
Spirit pray for believers? Why can he be
grieved, etc.? Why is he referred to as
he and himself?
Why is he distinguished from the father
and Jesus both in John 14, but equated
with both of them in equality?
Jesus said he and the father would send
the holy spirit, not send their presence
in their physical absence.
Again, this is numinological heresy, a
false Holy Spirit that's not real.
Yet, this guy was sent around to teach
this to people.
And again, it's always coming at the
behest of well, Ellen White confirmed it
in a vision.
Now, this is from a question that an SDA
submitted to James White to then ask uh
Lowber. And notice his answer.
Question one,
what serious objection is there to the
doctrine of the trinity? Answer,
there are many objections which we might
urge, but on account of our limited
space, we shall reduce them to to uh to
the three following. One, it is contrary
to common sense.
Two, it's contrary to scripture. Three,
its origin is pagan and fabulous.
These positions we will remark upon
briefly in their order. One, it is not
very cons uh uh consonant with common
sense to talk of three being one and one
being three or as some express it
calling God the triune God or the three
one God. If father, son, and holy ghost
are each god, it would be three gods.
For three times one is not one but
three. There is a sense in which they
are one but not one person as claimed by
trinitarians.
Trinitarians believe three.
We believe there are three persons but
one person.
If these objections were not damnably
heretical, it might actually be comical.
It's like folks, you have to remember in
the 1800s when this is being written,
you're talking about 1,400 years since
the systematizing of the doctrine of the
trinity. Systematized, not invented, not
discovered, not proposed or any of the
other misrepresent misrepres uh
representations that you have.
1,400 years people have been catechizing
their children in basic Christian
doctrine before these jokers even came
onto the scene and all of a sudden this
doctrine's absurd. It means three gods
and so on.
No. No. Instead of utilizing Aam's razor
and realizing no, it's these guys that
are totally ridiculous and had no clue
what they were talking about. It's
everyone else that's universally been
wrong for 2,000 years.
If this guy actually understood the
terms person and being that they're not
the same, he'd understand why the
trinity is not three gods.
Three who's is not three whats. God is a
title for the what, not the who.
He goes on in his in his response, I
mean, it's a long write up in that that
article. You can look it up. He goes on
in his response to say John 17 Jesus's
high priestly prayer refutes the trinity
once again as if the church for 2,000
years hasn't been aware of the high
priestly prayer of Christ
instead of just stopping to think, you
know, those that came before me were
probably aware of this paricopy. I
wonder what they said about it. No, no,
instead they just asserted this
silliness. Have you ever read John 17,
bro?
Yeah, good one.
We need to understand all of scripture
in total, folks. Not cherrypicked proof
texts.
It's one thing to site a proof text to
to to say a general point.
But if the general point that you're
making causes conflict contextually,
maybe it's time to reconsider your
understanding.
Because John 17 has to be understood not
just with in the context of what all of
John's has said before John 17 in 16
chapters
but in light of all of scripture.
The guy literally goes on to claim the
trinity is a pagan concept adapted to
fit with Christianity. I mean seriously.
He says it's a Persian concept. Just
silliness. Not even a serious person.
It's like the equivalent of the
modern-day internet conspiracy theorist
that sadly is a victim of the Dunning
Krueger effect. Dunning Krueger is where
a person thinks they know more than they
do, but they don't recognize that they
think they know more than they do.
All that to say, JN Lowber, heretic.
Next up, WH Little John. This guy was an
SDA pastor in the 1860s. He was a part
of the movers and shakers like Gry
Smith, James White, GI Butler and so on.
He traveled around preaching with them,
etc. He was involved in getting the
Battle Creek College back up and going,
wrote a lot about like uh sort of the
similar stuff that I do, pmical
apologetic material. This is what he
said in the review and herald in
response to the question,
do you believe sins were atoned for on
the cross? And this is the answer he
recommends that Adventists give.
Quote,
I believe there's not a single Bible
passage among those usually employed to
prove that the atonement took place at
the cross that will justify such a
conclusion.
The doctrine itself is contrary to
reason.
When sin is atoned for, it's fully
disposed of and can never be charged to
the account of the offender again. To
reason, therefore, that the sins of
those who are converted were atoned for
on the cross would be to argue that such
persons could not be lost. Close quote.
Abject heresy.
So like Uriah Smith, this guy was
telling Adventists that it's contrary to
reason to believe the atonement took
place at Calvary.
Further evidencing that when I tell you
guys this movement believes the cross
was simply where the atoning sacrifice
took place, not the atonement.
I'm not talking out the side of my neck.
This guy had no clue what he's talking
about. For starters, scripture is clear.
Clear.
Without the shedding of blood, there is
no remission of sins. Hebrews 9:22,
which is a citation and quote from the
Old Testament, Leviticus,
which means if blood is not being shed,
no sins are remitted.
Remission means what?
Cancellation.
Look it up. That's what remission means.
Cancellation. Without the shedding of
blood, there can be no cancelling of
sin.
Atonement is the act of reconciliation
whereby the hostility between God and
man is removed.
So as Paul says in Ephesians 2, mankind
is by nature a child of wrath.
You are born in Satan's kingdom. You're
not born in God's kingdom. You're not
born in between both kingdoms. And then
at a certain point after you do
something now, you're you're making your
choice into one kingdom. No, you are
born a fallen son or daughter of Adam, a
child of wrath.
When one is reconciled to God,
that hostility is gone.
Which is why the phrase propitiation
is so important.
Adventist theology proper has to twist
this word to mean something that it does
not.
Propitiation has to do with what was
done when the blood was sprinkled on the
mercy seat. So if you study the Old
Testament and you understand what was
done when the blood was sprinkled on the
mercy seat, the word propitiation, look
it up. The Greek word is hilsterion.
That's the transliteration of it. It
means to appease wrath.
So when Christ tells us that or or sorry
when scripture tells us that Christ was
a propitiatory sacrifice,
that means his sacrifice appeased that
wrath that is coming for the wicked.
First Corin or 1 Thessalonians 1:10.
Instead, Christ satisfied the punishment
for his people.
This is because God must punish sin.
Why? Because he is just. We were talking
about the ontological uh aspect of God
earlier, his attributes. One of them is
that God is just.
Because he is just by nature, he's fair.
That means he can't let sin slide or he
wouldn't be just.
Think about a judge that would somebody
comes into a courtroom,
it's verified 100% they are guilty and
he goes, "Eh, I'll let it slide." He's
not a just judge.
This is what Romans 3 is getting at when
it says God is both the just and the
justifier of the one who believes.
Notice Romans 3:21-6.
Romans 3:21-6.
But now the righteousness of God has
been manifested apart from the law,
although the law and the prophets bear
witness to it. The righteousness of God
through faith in Jesus Christ for all
who believe. For there's no distinction.
All have sinned and fall short of the
glory of God and are justified by his
grace as a gift through the redemption
that is in Christ Jesus whom God put
forward
as a propitiation
by his blood to be received by faith.
This was to show God's righteousness
because in his divine forbearance he had
passed over former sins. It was to show
his righteousness at the present time so
that he might be just and the justifier
of the one who has faith in Jesus. Close
quote.
The evidence that God is righteous was
demonstrated in the sacrifice of Jesus
at Calvary. And what was he put forth
as?
A propitiatory
sacrifice.
And this was the proof that God is holy,
righteous, and just, and does not let
sin slide.
The cross was a revelation to the world
that God is who he says he is, that he's
just, that he's merciful, that he's uh
all sorts of things. And in doing so, he
also justifies those who put their faith
in Christ, making God not only just, but
the justifier.
So when understanding that atonement has
to do with reconciliation and the
hostility between God and man being
eliminated,
yes, scripture does teach that atonement
took place at the cross.
really in the entire spectrum of the
work of Christ, his sinless life, death,
burial, resurrection, and ascension,
etc.
The real issue is not scripture. It's
that scripture doesn't fit with the
great controversy worldview. So, they
have to make these outlandish claims and
heretical statements because at least
this guy was smart enough to make the
connection that when sin is atoned for,
it's removed. Yes, that's exactly
correct, sir.
The application of the work of Christ on
behalf of the sinner takes place at the
point of faith. So it isn't that people
are born saved but through faith God
justifies the sinner.
This also completely falsifies the
central governing point of the SDA great
controversy worldview which is that God
is vindicating his character through a
seven-step program called the sanctuary.
No, God vindicated his character,
demonstrated he is who he says he is at
Calvary.
Furthermore, continuing in Romans, Paul
spends the next chapter talking in
Romans 4 talking about justification. He
uses Abraham as an example, but then
notice how he starts chapter 5 as he
transitions to discussing
reconciliation.
For while we were still weak at the
right time, Christ died for the ungodly.
For one will scarcely die for a
righteous person, though perhaps for a
good person one would dare even to die.
But God shows his love for us in that
while we were still sinners, Christ died
for us. Since therefore we have now been
justified by his blood,
much more shall we be saved by him from
the wrath of God, propitiation.
For if while we were enemies, we were
reconciled to God by the death of his
son, much more now that we are
reconciled, shall we be saved by his
life. More than that, we also rejoice in
God through our Lord Jesus Christ,
through whom we have now received
reconciliation.
Believers are saved from the wrath to
come. The same thing that Paul says in 1
Thessalonians 1:10. Because Christ bore
the wrath to come for his people at
Calvary. That's what propitiation is.
Which is why through his death, we are
reconciled to God. We have received.
You got past, present, and future here.
Have received reconciliation.
Well, according to to to whittle John,
no, you're not reconciled yet. You can't
be reconciled if your sin is still
looming and standing against you.
That would mean there's still active
hostility between God and his people.
Reconciliation means that hostility
hostility is gone. See you. Goodbye.
Sayanara.
We are also plainly told by Jeremiah
regarding the new covenant what one of
the promises of the new covenant is. And
it's in contrast to the Mosaic covenant.
So the author of Hebrews cites Jeremiah
31 in Hebrews 8:6-13.
Notice
lot here.
But as it is, Christ has obtained a
ministry that is as much more excellent
than the old as the as the covenant he
mediates is better since it is enacted
on what?
Better promises.
For if the first covenant had been
faultless,
there would have been no occasion to
look for a second.
for he finds fault with them when he
says, "Behold, the days are coming,
declares the Lord, when I will establish
a new covenant with the house of Israel
and with the house of Judah,
not like the covenant that I made with
their fathers on the day when I took
them by the hand to bring them out of
the land of Egypt.
For they did not continue in my
covenant, and so I showed no concern for
them, declares the Lord. For this is the
covenant that I will make with the house
of Israel after those days, declares the
Lord. I will put my laws in their minds
and write them on their hearts, and I
will be their God, and they shall be my
people. And they shall not teach each
one his neighbor, and each one his
brother, saying, "Know the Lord." For
they shall all know me, from the least
of them to the greatest. For I will be
merciful toward their iniquities. that
sin and I will remember their sins no
more.
In speaking of a new covenant, he makes
the first one obsolete and what is
becoming obsolete and growing old is
ready to vanish away.
Once again, when we understand Jude 5
says Jesus led Israel out of the
wilderness, here we see Jesus is the one
that made the new covenant with his
people. again demonstrating Jesus is not
some lesser lord or some lesser divine
being. He is the almighty. So the new
covenant is a better covenant that the
one enacted with mo or over and against
the one enacted with Moses and national
Israel because it's enacted on what?
Better promises.
This is essentially what the author
highlights throughout the whole book.
all the ways that Jesus is better. But
specifically, notice verse 12.
One of the better promises of the new
covenant is that God remembers the sins
of those in the covenant no more.
Unlike in the Mosaic where the blood of
animals didn't actually atone for sins,
they only covered them, which is why
they had to keep doing the process over
and over and over and had a day of
atonement every year.
Jesus's holy blood actually atones for
sin by taking it away, and God remembers
it no more. Because what does Hebrews
10:4 say?
For it is impossible for the blood of
bulls and goats to take away sins.
So understand that the blood of Christ,
unlike the blood of animals, takes away
sins, which is why it's better than
animals. And one of the better promises
of the new covenant is that the blood
has taken away the sins of those within
the covenant. Which is why in Hebrews
9:24-6, the author goes on to say this.
For Christ has entered not into holy
places made with hands, which are copies
of the true things, but into heaven
itself.
Now to appear in the presence of God on
our behalf, nor was it to offer himself
repeatedly as the high priest enters the
holy places every year with blood not
his own. For then he would have had to
suffer repeatedly since the foundation
of the world. But as it is, he has
appeared once for all at the end of the
ages to put away sin by the sacrifice of
himself.
No, no, but wait. Wh Little John told us
it's contrary to reason to believe that
sin was put away at the cross
because he said atonement didn't take
place there since when sin is atoned
for, it's gone and can't be charged to a
person's account.
I know the guy was physically blind.
Maybe that's the problem
because according to this guy, the first
covenant isn't obsolete because a
person's sins aren't actually atoned for
yet.
Just like they weren't in the Mosaic
covenant. They're only being covered
because they have their whole
investigative judgment
there where sins are standing on record
in heaven for Jesus to investigate and
deal with. How he's doing that, their
scholars can't tell me. I've I've tried
to ask them. I'm like, is he shedding
his blood up there?
How did the blood get there?
Because without the shedding of blood,
there's no forgiveness of sins.
Yet, Hebrews is is clear as we just saw.
Jesus sh suffered the shedding of blood
once at Calvary.
But in their system, the new covenant's
just like the old in this regard. Sin is
still remembered despite the text
explicitly saying, "God remembers the
sins of his people no more because
Christ atoned for them at Calvary and
put them away."
Colossians 1 19-20.
For in him all the fullness of God was
pleased to dwell, and through him to
reconcile himself all things, whether on
earth or in heaven, making peace
by the blood of his cross.
Sin is why there is hostility between
God and sinners.
But Christ's propitiatory sacrifice
appeased God's just condemnation.
By him punishing sin
in the person of Christ, but justifying
sinners and by the blood of Christ's
cross, that hostility is removed.
There's peace.
Adventists love to point to Hebrews 9 to
try and say it supports the
investigative judgment
where it says heaven is also being
cleansed. So that proves the
investigative judgment's true except no,
the sacrifice of Christ at Calvary is
what did so for both heaven and earth.
Not peace by the blood shed at the cross
and then halted for 1800 some odd years
to then begin in a cleansing work in
heaven that will go on from 1844 till
whenever where Jesus isn't actually
shedding blood but he's blotting out
sins with it in a literal temple
building in heaven. No, the sins aren't
remembered anymore. That's part of the
bitterness of the new covenant. And
Jesus put sin away at Calvary making
peace by the blood of his cross. and
he's seated in heaven. Unlike the
Levitical priests who never sat down
because there was no throne in the
temple,
they were always standing, working,
dealing with sin. Christ is seated in
heaven ruling and reigning as a priest,
king, a simultaneous work like
MelkiseDC,
not standing dealing with sin like the
Levites.
That is what's actually contrary to
reason. Not that atonement took place at
the cross. It's contrary to reason. Yet
the SDA church wants to tell us they're
now they now believe atonement took
place at the cross. Sort of
because they don't affirm what what
little John said there.
Dez for documents this in his book
Daniel 8:14 and and the investigative
judgment where he does a systematic
representation of this. And that book
was be before the 21st century. And even
in there, he recognizes that from the
19th to the 20th century after this
heretic, they're like, "Well, atonement
did take place at the cross." Kind of
sort of. Which is why their scholars
will say stuff like, "We believe in a
completed incomplete atonement. It's
just neverending confusion and just
illogic."
It's like, it's part of the reason I
can't remain Adventists. I can't remain
just being like having to having to
thwart my my critical thinking and and
just this is illogical. It doesn't make
sense.
But this is why it's inconsistent for
Adventists to claim that they are
reconciled to God right now. And you'll
often see me asking them that question.
Do you have peace with God? That's a
leading question I always start with in
discussing with SDAs. Are you currently
reconciled to God? Because that's the
conundrum. No. In that system, you're
not.
This is something still future to be
determined.
They don't actually know what the future
holds because salvation ultimately comes
down to the individual holding up their
end of the bargain.
Their sins are still looming over them.
Despite Paul saying there's no
condemnation for those in Christ Jesus,
the way the Adventist Church defines
being in Christ Jesus, there is still
condemnation for you potentially.
Next quote. Another question and answer
in the review and herald.
The question, will you please favor me
with those scriptures which plainly say
that Christ is a created being? Answer.
You are mistaken in supporting that 7th
day Adventists teach that Christ was
ever created. They believe on the
contrary that he was begotten of the
father and that he can properly be
called God and worshiped as such. They
believe also that the worlds and
everything which is was created by
Christ in conjunction with the father.
They believe however that somewhere in
the eternal ages of the past there was a
point at which Christ came into
existence.
Also notice folks by worlds they mean
all these other worlds with unfallen
beings on them that all keep the ten
commandments and are looking in on the
great controversy etc.
He continues, "They think that it is
necessary that God should have have
addated Christ in his being in order
that Christ could have been begotten of
him and sustained to him the relation of
son. They hold to the distinct
personality of the father and son
rejecting as absurd that feature of
trinitarianism
which insists that God and Christ and
the holy spirit are three persons and
yet but one person.
SDAs hold that God and Christ are one in
a sense that Christ prayed for his
disciples might that his disciples might
be one in an example one in spirit
purpose and labor. Close quote.
So, first notice no mention of the Holy
Spirit being involved in creation.
Jerry Moon recognizes that same thing in
his paper regarding Ellen White. She
didn't include the Holy Spirit in the
work of creation, which as we saw is
because she didn't believe the Holy
Spirit was a conscious person at the
time of writing those things. But this
quote is a perfect example of the
illogic of Adventism.
He says, "Jesus wasn't created, but at
some point in the past, he came into
existence.
It's like, is it any shock that this
movement is a total mess of confusion,
Ted?
And the evidence that this guy himself
was confused is that what he said
regarding God being three persons but
one person.
No, Trinitarians don't believe that,
completely clueless.
Yet again, we see the distinction
between person and being is so
important, but we're the ones that are
confused. It's us that are the total
confused. Yeah.
Notice what this guy says makes the
heavenly trio one. Not their being,
meaning their mode of existence, but
they're united in a mission and a
purpose. Just like Ted Wilson said in
the opening clip, folks, that is not one
God.
That's not one God, my friend. I'm not
saying that they're not united in their
purpose and mission. I am. But that's
not what makes them one God.
Jerry Moon and other SDA scholars want
to tell us they're trinitarians and
they've reformed. Yet in his paper, this
is the exact claim he makes about how
the heavenly trio is one God.
Ultimately, because Ellen White's
utilization of John that little John put
forth.
And by John I mean the book of John. The
way Ellen put put Jesus forth in the
book of John is how little John here.
John and little John. That's how John
Little John here is using that. So all
that to say Walcott Hackne little John
heretic
John G. Madison. Now first notice folks
what the Encyclopedia of 7th Day
Adventists says in part about this guy.
quote, "Madison's legacy is vast.
Organizing the work in three
Scandinavian countries as well as
planting numerous Scandinavian churches
in the American Midwest from the from
scratch, spreading the gospel of the
love of Jesus through his writings and
publishing as well as teaching and
public campaigns. Besides his widespread
organizing of the Scandinavian Adventist
churches, his legacy was also
theological. The deeply evangelical
christoacentric focus of his preaching
coupled with a genuine interest in the
saving of souls for Jesus influenced the
approach of Adventism in Scandinavia,
not the least in Sweden. This focus
would remain for most of the 100 plus
years ahead.
Close quote. Let's look at the Jesus
that Mr. Madison was preaching and
leading people to
quote Christ is the only literal son of
God, the only begotten of the father.
John 1:14. He is God because he is the
son of God.
Not by virtue of his resurrection.
I'm going to repeat this. He is God
because he is the son of God not by
virtue of his resurrection.
If Christ is the only begotten of the
father then we cannot be begotten of the
father in a literal sense. It can only
be in a secondary sense of the word.
Close quote.
So we are going to look at the term
begotten. I mentioned it earlier and
this is why I wanted to wait. He says
Jesus is the literal son of God. By this
they mean Jesus was brought forth into
being at a point or into had a beginning
at a point in the past. He's not the
eternal God, the almighty.
But before doing that, we have to
examine how poor yet another one of
these pioneers understanding was. Notice
Romans 1 1-4, specifically verse 4.
Paul, a servant of Christ Jesus, called
to be an apostle, set apart for the
gospel of God, which he promised
beforehand through his prophets in the
holy scriptures concerning his son, who
was descended from David according to
the flesh, and was a and was declared to
be the son of God in power according to
the spirit of holiness.
How?
by his resurrection from the dead.
Jesus Christ our Lord.
But hold up. John Madison's Jesus who
was conceived at a point in the past and
brought forth into existence was not the
son of God by virtue of the resurrection
but by virtue of being being brought
forth.
Wrong.
No. Romans Romans 1:4 says Jesus was
declared to be the son of God by his
resurrection
which means that yes he is God by virtue
of his resurrection.
It's like folks these were not bright
thinkers. This is who God used to raise
up and restore the church that never
disappeared.
Now when it comes to the word begotten,
the Greek word monog,
it does not mean that Jesus had a
beginning
like these pioneers believed. All
anti-trinitarians try appealing to this
begotten but no.
Notice this paragraph from Table Talk
magazine. Excellent publication. I
cannot recommend it more highly.
This is from one of their devotions on
specifically begottenness and
procession.
What makes the three persons of the
trinity differ from one another is a
difference in relations, not in
attributes.
From the early church fathers through
the Protestant reformers to today,
Orthodox Christianity has said that what
makes the father the father is that he
is eternally unbegotten. And what makes
the son the son is that he is eternally
begotten.
Evidence for this is found in passages
such as John 1:18, which in the King
James refers to the son as begotten.
This is a better translation of the
Greek than in some newer English English
versions. For the underlying Greek word
has to do with generation.
The son is eternally generated by the
father.
This generation or begottenness never
had a beginning
never had a beginning. The son has
always existed and has always been fully
God even though he is begotten of the
father.
And the father has always begotten the
son such that the son and the father are
both fully God. Close quote.
So they start by explaining what I did
earlier regarding the economic and
ontological trinity. Their differences
are in relation not attributes.
But then notice the explanation of
begotten.
It simply means that Jesus eternally
proceeds from the father which the SDA
church to this day still rejects.
what is called eternal procession or
eternal generation of the son. The
eternal proceeding forth from the father
of the son.
This is why it is wrong to say that
Jesus is self-existent
like Ellen White erroneously claimed.
No, he is not.
That what's self-existent is the one
God, father, son, and spirit. You're
dividing them at the wrong level. You're
dividing them ontologically, not
economically.
The point being the term begotten does
not mean that Jesus had a beginning like
Uriah Smith tried saying meant in the
quotes we looked at earlier. It doesn't.
This discussion is not new to the 19th
century. It is old, folks. long before
the SDAs,
which is why I constantly say these
folks simply resurrected a bunch of
ancient heresy that God already led the
church through and then tries to claim
like a thousand years later, no, no, no,
we're resurrecting truth.
Wow. Okay.
So, John G. Madison, heretic.
JHW Wagner, Joseph Wagner,
he was close with uh James White. He was
the editor of uh Signs of the Times for
a while. Notice what he says regarding
the Trinity and the atonement.
Many theologians really think that the
atonement in respect to its dignity and
efficacy rests upon the doctrine of the
Trinity.
But we fail to see any connection
between the two. To the contrary, the
advocates of that doctrine really fall
into the difficulty which they seem
anxious to avoid. Their difficulty
consists of this. They take the denial
of a trinity to be equivalent to a
denial of the divinity of Christ. Were
that the case, we should cling to the
doctrine of a trinity as tenaciously as
they can. But it is not the case. They
who have read our remarks on the death
of the son of God know that we firmly
believe in the divinity of Christ. But
we cannot accept the idea of a trinity
as it is held by trinitarians without
giving up our claim on the dignity of
the sacrifice made for our redemption.
Close quote.
Then I guess the SDA church gave up
their claim on the dignity of the
sacrifice made for redemption because
they claim to be trinitarians now and
will assure us they believe like
Christians do.
This is the favorite excuse of all the
Aryanleaning SDAs.
They'll tell you, "No, no, we believe
Jesus is divine. We believe Jesus is
God, but he's not the eternal God, the
Almighty."
Which means you either have two gods or
one that is a lesser divine being and
the other the Almighty or that Jesus
isn't God. No amount of mental
gymnastics will fix this.
The real issue that this heretic wasn't
bright enough to actually recognize is
that while it does have implications for
Christ's atonement, the far more
pressing issue is that by rejecting the
Trinity, you have a different God.
Lowercase G, an idol that's not real.
Because the triune God is the only true
God. And he's revealed himself as
father, son, and spirit. The singular
name that someone is baptized in. Not
names but name. The name of the father,
son, and the spirit. That's the one God.
These heretics have a different God
entirely.
The Holy Spirit isn't personal, meaning
has the ability to will, speak, and be
spoken to. The son's not the almighty
eternal God, but a lesser divine being.
He's not created, but he had a
beginning, which means no, you're not
the commandment keepers. You're
violating all four of the first
commandments, which are all god-facing,
and you have a false god violating the
first commandment, specifically all the
dominoes now fall.
Now, he's going to explain his last
sentence of that quote regarding
trinitarians apparently having to give
up the the dignity of the atonement.
And here is shown how remarkably the
widest extremes meet in theology. The
highest trinitarians and lowest
unitarians meet and are perfectly united
on the death of Christ. The faith of
both amounts to sinianism.
Unitarians believe that Christ was a
prophet, an inspired teacher, but merely
human. That is death was that of a human
body only. Trinitarians hold that the
term Christ comprehends two distinct and
separate natures. one that was merely
human, the other the second person of
the Trinity who dwelt in the flesh for a
brief period
but could not possibly suffer or die.
That the Christ that died was only the
human nature in which the divinity had
dwelt.
Both classes have a human offering and
nothing more. No matter how exalted the
pre-existent son was, no matter how
glorious, how powerful, or even eternal,
if the manhood only died, the sacrifice
was only human.
And so far as the the vicarious death of
Christ is concerned, this is so
sinianism. Thus, the remark is just that
the doctrine of a trinity degrades the
atonement, resting it solely on a human
offering as a basis. Close quote.
No, what degrades the atonement is
saying no atonement took place at the
cross. These flaming heretics. But this
really says it all. This guy claims that
when it comes to the atonement,
trinitarians and unitarians are united
because
I'm sorry, folks.
It just
trinitarians and unitarians are united
because both parties only believe Christ
sacrifice.
Sorry, man. It's just hard to take this
stuff seriously. It's like
then he makes the laughable assertion
that both amount to sinianism.
is coming from the movement that handles
the Bible exactly like the Sinians
completely detaching it from history.
The same movement that assert asserts no
creed but the Bible.
I'm sorry folks.
the same movement. That's a a total
theological freefor-all.
I'm sorry.
The movement that claims
no creed but the Bible, just like the
Sinians,
which is why the Sinians were a total
theological free-for-all, completely
untethered from Christian history, went
totally rogue as a novel sect that ended
up embracing all sorts of ancient
heresy. Gee, exactly like the SDA church
to make the charge that Unitarians,
which is what the Sinians were, and
trinitarians affirm the same thing
regarding the atonement.
For starters, he said, "Trinitarians
affirm that Jesus dwelt in the flesh for
a brief period."
Uh, no, sir. Trinitarians
Trinitarians, which is the classical
Christian position, believe that Jesus
will forever retain his physical
resurrected, glorified body and will
dwell with his people in union as such
forever.
This is literally central to our
theology around the incarnation.
It's implicit in what we put forth
regarding Jesus's priesthood being a
forever work.
Something I'm constantly bringing up
regarding the investigative judgment
being a blasphemous heretical doctrine,
which it's claimed that Jesus will cease
his work as mediator at a point in the
future. Not even close. Hebrews 7 is
clear. Jesus is a priest forever. This
was foretold of in the psalter.
And that he lives forever to make
intercession for his people. This speaks
to the incarnation as Jesus incarnating
was God bridging the gap between God and
man. The word the second person of the
Godhead added unto himself human flesh.
In him the fullness of the Godhead
dwells bodily. This is how Jesus is
forever our mediator between God and
man. Because the fullness of God himself
added unto himself, human flesh came
down to our level what's called the
condescension of Christ. and he remains
with the physical glorified body that he
resurrected in forever to stay with us.
So this guy had no clue what he was
talking about and didn't even realize
that trinitarians are not gnostics.
We don't believe Jesus is some
disembodied spirit. He's the God man.
Then he tried to say trinitarians and
unarians both only have a human offering
taking place. This is supposed to be how
uh we're united with Unitarians when it
comes to the atonement. Yeah. No, dude.
When trinitarians say only Jesus's human
nature died, that doesn't mean his
sacrifice was not of divine value.
When trinitarians say only Jesus's human
nature died, they are essentially saying
God can't die. That's why his divine
nature didn't die because God can't die.
That doesn't mean that his sacrifice as
a man was not still of divine value.
That's the kicker. Which makes his
criticism completely null and void. His
logical syllogism is this. If only
Jesus's human nature died and not his
divine human nature, then it was only a
human offering.
No. Bad logic. That's a faulty
syllogism. His human sacrifice of his
human body, his human bodily nature made
the atonement for humans possible, but
wasn't totally unique in so much as it
was a it was of divine value by nature
because Christ was fully divine as well.
The divine nature cannot die because God
by nature can't die. Christ's divinity
did not need to die in order for the
sacrifice of the whole person of Christ
to be what was offered.
Death is a human attribute, not a divine
attribute. And this shows you they don't
understand the hypothatic union. The two
natures of Christ are ascribed to the
single person, one person. You can't
divide the two natures. That's why you
get all these other heresies that popped
up that that the church had to deal
with. Well, Christ has has is two
natures, two persons. No, he's not.
But since these pioneers didn't
understand this, the two natures of
Christ, and how that's arrived at from
scripture, they brought these totally
useless critiques that don't even hit
the mark.
This coming from the same people who are
going to cite 1 Timothy 6:16 to say only
God has immortality.
To be consistent, they'd have to say
that only applies to the father, not
Jesus. Because if Jesus was human and
divine and both natures died, Jesus
isn't the Almighty, but a lesser God
with the capability of his divinity
dying.
Which is precisely what the SDA church
still affirms to this day. They believe
that when Jesus died, just like they
believe about every other human, he
ceased to exist for three days.
I brought this up in SDA University in a
religion class to Jud Lake and he
admitted it creates problems regarding
scripture clearly stating that the
universe is upheld by Christ and that
God can't die. But notice what Ellen
White says.
Jesus said to Mary, "Touch me not for I
am not yet ascended to my father." When
he closed his eyes in death upon the
cross, the soul of Christ did not go to
he go at once to heaven as many believe.
Or how could his words be true? I am not
yet ascended to my father. The spirit of
Jesus slept in the tomb with his body
and did not wing its way to heaven.
there to maintain a separate existence,
and to look down upon the morning
disciples, embalming the body from which
it had taken flight. All that comprised
the life and intelligence of Jesus
remained with his body in the sephiler,
and when he came forth, it was as a
whole being. He did not have to summon
his spirit from heaven. He had power to
lay down his life and to take it up
again. Close quote.
Folks, God does not sleep. This is a
human attribute. Yet she claims that
Jesus slept in the tomb. All that
comprised him
that was laid in the tomb was no
different than any other human. Except
no, Jesus is the unique incarnate one.
He's fully divine and fully human. Yes,
with two natures. And the modern SDA
church tries to affirm this now,
which is precisely why the anti-heavenly
trio folks in their ranks are arguing
with them, claiming they have
apostasized from the roots of the
pioneers. uh which was correct
supposedly. The point being, no, Jesus's
divine nature did not die. This is part
of why the incarnation is such an
important doctrine. When you affirm the
Kosis heresy like the SDA church does,
this is the problem you run into. The
Kosis heresy is the claim that Jesus set
his divinity aside when he incarnated
and was only a man while on earth.
Except no, divine attributes are
ascribed to the single person which is
both human and divine. After he added
unto himself divinity, you can't divide
the two natures.
I'm sorry. You can't do that.
And to claim that the Christian church
has been confused on this for 2,000
years, no, you're a fool to say
something like this. You don't know what
you're talking about.
But now,
because we have to
demonstrate this with sources,
what's my source for this? Notice what
does the SDA church's website say on a
page titled, "What Adventists believe
about the life, death, and resurrection
of Christ?"
Notice
me zoom in here for you.
What does it say?
Jesus came to experience life as we do,
as 100% human. Out of love for every
single one of us, he chose to be
stripped of his glory. Philippians
2:6-8. And was given no advantage over
us when it came to living a life without
sinning. The word became flesh and dwelt
among us. John 1:14. But this made him
no less divine. Jesus was still 100%
God.
This concept that Jesus is and then they
bold it 100% God and 100% man can be
mind-boggling. But this was necessary in
God's plan to deliver us from the grip
of sin while the great controversy rages
on. Meaning both good and evil surround
us daily waring against one another.
So Jesus as part of the Godhead had to
live a perfect life.
Then his innocent blood could cover our
sins and make it possible for us to
inherit eternal life. Notice cover sins.
What did we see in in Hebrews earlier
about what makes the new covenant
better? No, it's not just covered like
the blood of bulls and goats removed.
You still see the pioneers ideas
undergirling all of this. But they
continue. Notice
Philippians 2 6-8 says that even though
Jesus is God, he set his divine nature
aside and took on human nature. He came
to serve us to show us God's love for us
to live as our example. He came to
minister to people through his perfect
obedient life. He obeyed the father in
every way, even when it led to hum to a
humiliating death on a cross.
Notice they try and pay lip service to
the hypothetic union that Jesus is 100%
God, 100% man. He's the God man. But
then they went on to say what about
Philippians 2 6-12 or 6-8 technically
that upon incarnating he set his
divinity aside. This is the Kosis
interpretation of Philippians 2 which is
a heresy.
The glory of Christ was indeed veiled
like they said in the first paragraph in
his incarnation, but he did not set
aside his divine nature.
There's a difference there. Divine
attributes are ascribed to the incarnate
Christ. He didn't set that aside. As we
saw, he forgave sins. Only God can
forgive sins. If he was only a man while
on earth, he couldn't forgive sins.
But what we see here is the fruit of
these heretical pioneers trying to be
merged with the more modern
understanding and some branches of SDA
leadership trying to embrace certain
aspects of orthodoxy. No, sorry. Does
not work that way. That results in
contradictions, which is exactly what
that section of the web page says. The
hypothatic union and the Kosis Harry uh
Kosis heresy are not compatible.
Yet they're trying to play both sides,
creating contradictions.
And this is why you don't come along in
the 19th century and think you're
smarter than everyone else that came
before you. They were all stooges of the
Roman Catholic Church with the Trinity
only being accepted because, well, the
winners of history wrote the history.
No, the Trinity poses zero problems for
the atonement. Nor are Trinitarians
functionally cinian when it comes to the
atonement. Tell us you don't understand
Sinianism and Trinitarianism without
telling us that you don't know either.
So this guy JH Wagner, certified
heretic, his son EJ Wagner,
lots of Adventists love to point to this
guy and his efforts in justification by
faith, which they don't mean the same
thing Christians do, to say Adventism
since Wagner is different. They got the
gospel right.
Yeah. Well, unfortunately, when you're a
christoologgical heretic, you can't
possibly have the gospel correct because
the gospel is Jesus Christ's gospel
according to Galatians 1:12, which means
if you have the wrong Jesus, you don't
have his gospel.
Notice Signs of the Times, April 8,
1889, the year immediately after the
1888 Minneapolis General Conference
debacle regarding justification by
faith.
quote, "While both are of the same
nature,
the Father is the first in point of
time,
he's also greater in that he had no
beginning, while Christ's personality
had a beginning."
Close quote. Look at the year, folks,
1889.
This blasphemous heresy is still around
and being taught by SDA authority
figures up to the turn of the century.
Uh, no. They don't possess the same
nature. Then, Wagner, this is insight
into how SDA theology even has a use a
unique understanding of what nature
means.
And remember, in this systems theology,
person means having a literal tangible
form. What he is not saying is that
Jesus began to exist at his physical
birth, but that at a point in the past
before the creation of the earth, Jesus
was brought forth into being. The father
alone had no beginning, just like these
other heretics we looked at. This is
damnable heresy. It's a false Christ.
Jesus Christ is Yahweh, folks. Jehovah.
This idea of breaking apart the Godhead
into different parts like this creates
two issues you've had with Adventism
from their inception.
You either have the father being the
supreme and the son being inferior and
the holy spirit not even being a person
or you get where they are now which is
functionally tritheism where they try
and claim that the three persons are
co-equal co-eternal but Jesus still
lacks certain divine attributes such as
omnipresence. He's present through the
Holy Spirit who now they claim is a
person but is the person of the father
and the spirit's or the son's presence
in their physical absence.
Despite saying despite Jesus saying God
is spirit and spirit is immaterial
these pioneers to to them immaterial
meant not real which again is due to
their physicalist worldview. The point
being, no. Jesus had no beginning as the
father, son, and spirit are the eternal
God, the true God. EJ Wagner, certified
heretic.
Last but not least,
obviously no stranger, the prophetus.
Now, in the last funeral stream, folks,
we looked at a number of statements and
quotes from her. We're going to look at
some others now because at the end of
the day, she holds more weight and
authority than anyone else we've looked
at thus far and any living Adventist to
this day. You know, I recently had a guy
reach out about asking about SDA
theology. He talked to me about it and
then he went and talked to a bunch of
SDA SDA theologians. He got taken for a
ride.
He he got totally bamboozled. Poor guy.
Tried to tell him. I'm like, "Dude,
you got hoodwinkedked. you got
hoodwinkedked
because he tried to appeal to, well,
these scholars say this. Yeah, that
doesn't matter. That's irrelevant. What
matters is the ultimate authority
sources.
What matters is the great controversy
theme. What matters is what Ellen White
says.
She holds far more authority than any
anybody else.
So, we're going to pay particular
attention this time to the great
controversy narrative and look at how
much of this mess and confusion is
rooted in that and part of why
eradicating this from the movement will
essentially be an impossible feat
without wiping out the whole house of
cards.
Okay, from the great controversy,
but it's also in the SDA Bible
commentary.
Quote, "Before the entrance of sin among
the angels, Christ the Word, the only
begotten of God, was one with the
eternal father, one in nature, in
character, and in purpose,
the only being
in all of the univer
that could enter into all the councils
and purposes of God.
By Christ the Father wrought in the
creation of all heavenly beings. Close
quote.
So what do they mean by begotten?
Christ had a beginning at a point in the
past. The father is the eternal one, the
eternal father. Yet just like EJ Wagner,
she says the father and Jesus are one in
nature, but the father's the eternal
one.
Remember, three great powers, plural,
like we saw toward the beginning, not
one power.
Adventists will point to statements like
this and say, "See, see, she says
they're of the same nature, thinking
that fixes things." But no, it doesn't.
Adam and Eve had the same nature. Yet,
they were still two different persons,
two different beings. They were not two
persons, one being.
Which is why in the very next sentence
she says Jesus was the only
being in all the universe that could
enter into God's uh God the Father's
councils. And as we saw earlier, that's
the act that made Lucifer jealous. I've
had SDA pastors try and tell me that SDA
theology proper understands the
distinction between person and being.
It's only the ley of their movement that
interchangeably used the two terms. Yet
here we have their own prophetist doing
such because either you have to say she
distinguishes the father and the son in
being which is damnable heresy or you
have to try and use the SDA defense that
uh she was using person and being
interchangeably
which circles us back to the issue
person and being are not the same thing.
There's no reconciling statements like
this with trinitarianism. They need to
just own that they're their own thing
and stand confidently on that idea and
that they have this special revelation
that no one else has that gives them the
answers to everything
and they're here to correct everyone
which is exactly what Herbert Douglas
said in the paper we've looked at
Ministry Magazine 2000 December 2000
where he says the the great controversy
theme is the God particle it is the
theory of everything that's why
Adventism has the antidote to
theological division
Yeah,
except they try and play word games and
insist that they're trinitarians when
their scholars outright state that they
reject Orthodox Trinitarianism and don't
mean what Christians do when they say
that. They've taken the word to appear
like the rest of us, which is dishonest,
commandmentkeeping church.
It knowingly confuses people. They need
to stick to the heavenly trio label. But
again in the same vein,
quote, "Satan was envious and jealous of
Jesus Christ. Christ had been taken into
the special counsel of God in regard to
his plans. While Satan was unacquainted
with them, he did not understand,
neither was he permitted to know the
purposes of God. But Christ was
acknowledged sovereign of heaven, his
power and authority to be the same as
that of God himself."
Satan thought that he himself a favorite
of heaven among the angels. Satan
thought that he was himself a favorite
in heaven among the angels. He had been
highly exalted, but this did not call
forth from him gratitude and praise to
his creator. He aspired to the height of
God himself. He glorified in his
loftiness. He knew that he was honored
by the angels. He had a special mission
to execute. He had been near the great
creator and the ceaseless beams of
glorious light enshrouded the eternal
God
or the the the ceaseless beams that
enshrouded the the eternal God had shone
especially upon him. Satan thought how
angels had had obeyed his command with
pleasurable elacrity. Were not his
garments light and beautiful? Why should
Christ thus be honored before him?
Close quote.
So, Satan was jealous of Jesus. Why?
Because the father, who is the eternal
God, chose to take Jesus into his
special counsel regarding his plans
regarding the creation of the earth. The
father's plan,
the father's plan. Jesus was unfamiliar
with these until he was let in on the
action. He was exalted to be made equal
with the father having the same
authority as his father which would mean
he didn't possess omnipotence or rather
omniscience from eternity past that is
distinct to the father.
This action on the father's part caused
Satan to begin asking why he wasn't the
one that was done that that this wasn't
done to. He thought all the angels loved
him and he was so beautiful. He was in
close contact with the ceaseless beams
of light shining forth from God the
Father. They shone especially upon him.
So why was Jesus honored before him?
Haven't Adventist show you this in the
Bible, folks. They can't. They'll point
to Ezekiel where it simply says Lucifer
was filled with pride. None of this
story about him being jealous because
Jesus was exalted.
Total fiction. Jesus was not exalted to
be made equal with the father. Jesus
created Lucifer. He was never given some
extra power and authority he didn't
always possess that caused Lucifer, a
creature, to now become jealous.
This is why the SDA view of the Godhead
is a divided mess.
They'll try and say, "No, no, no. We
believe Jesus is God. Look." Yet, what
they mean by that isn't that he's Yahweh
from eternity past and into eternity. He
isn't omnipresent. He lacks all sorts of
divine attributes that only the father
has, which shows that the term god in
SDA theology more closely resembles a
familial title, not a statement of
ontological being or state of.
But then she continues the narrative
where she reiterates the same thing
again.
All the heavenly host were summoned to
appear before the father to have each
case determined. Satan unblushingly made
known his dissatisfaction that Christ
should be preferred before him.
Preferred before him for what? Oh,
exaltation.
He stood up proudly and urged that he
should be equal with God. Oh, right.
Because Jesus was made equal with God
and should be taken into conference with
the father and understand his purposes.
God informed Satan that his son alone he
would reveal his secret purposes
that to his son and he required all the
family in heaven even Satan to yield him
in implicit unquestionable obedience but
that the that he Satan had proved
himself unworthy a place in heaven.
Close quote.
None of this is in scripture. Yet
they'll emphatically tell you, "We only
believe the Bible." No, you're kidding
yourself. But notice the interaction. He
claims that God told her,
"This is before the creation of the
earth. God the Father calls all the
angelic hosts before him."
After the announcement that Jesus has
been made equal with the father and is
to be obeyed, Satan supposedly
unblushingly made known his
dissatisfaction with this and claimed to
be shown that he had been or or claimed
he should have been the one that this
happened to. But then the father told
him that only Jesus would be revealed
the secret councils and purposes of the
father.
Does that sound like omniscience, folks?
Does that sound like uh Well, we'll get
to it in a moment.
The Adventist Jesus apparently isn't
omnisient either because he gained new
insight and information after the father
decided at a point in the past to
elevate him and give him access he
didn't previously have even though he's
God. They'll insist like Ted said, "We
believe three co- uh eternal persons."
Yeah. No, you don't.
That's just Christianes to try and sound
like you're trinitarians.
Well, maybe they'll say now, well, Jesus
is eternal.
We disagree with the pioneers that he
had a he had a beginning in the past.
He's co-eternal. Yeah, he's not Yahweh.
And as we've seen, the highest source of
authority in their movement
distinguishes Jesus as a distinct being
from the father that was exalted to be
made equal with the father, given an
exalted status that included gaining new
information and insights that he
previously did not have.
After all this transpires, she claims
that Lucifer continued in his rebellion
in heaven
was then booted to the earth after its
creation, kicked out of heaven. Adam and
Eve were created on the earth as a
probationary test to see if they would
stand or fall. Satan then tempts Eve.
She sins and then is used by Satan as a
false messenger to go tempt Adam, who
she also says was deceived, despite
scripture saying Adam wasn't deceived.
who then went on and sinned as well.
We've looked at how she botches Genesis
I don't even know how many times at this
point. But after all that happens, then
she had this to say.
Sorrow filled heaven. This is after the
fall of man. As it was realized that man
was lost and the world that God created
was to be filled with mortals doomed to
misery, sickness, and death. And there
was no way of escape for the offender.
The whole family of Adam must die. I saw
the lovely Jesus and behold an
expression of sympathy and sorrow upon
his countenance. Soon I saw him approach
the exceeding bright light which
enshrouded the father. Steed my
accompanying angel. He's in close
converse with his father. The anxiety of
the angels seemed to be intense while
Jesus was communing with his father.
Three times he was shut in by the
glorious light about the father. And the
third time he came from the uh and and
the third time he came from the father,
his person could be seen.
His countenance was calm, free from all
perplexity and trouble, and shown with
benevolence and loveliness such as words
cannot express. He then made known to
the angelic host that a way of escape
had been made for lost man.
had been made,
not a plan from eternity past.
He told them that he had been pleading
with his father and had offered to give
his life a ransom and take the sentence
of death upon himself, that through him
man might find pardon, that through the
merits of his blood and obedience to the
law of God, they could have favor with
God
and be brought into the beautiful garden
and eat of the fruit of the tree of
life. Close quote.
So now that man fell, the Adventist
Jesus proposed a plan to the father that
took three tries for him to accept.
Jesus had to plea with him.
Yet Jerry Moon told us in his paper that
if there's division in the purpose or
plan of the three heavenly trio members,
that would be polytheism.
Yet here you have them apparently not in
agreement. Jesus had to plead with the
father to accept a plan. Totally
ludicrous.
And again, this is now an afterthought.
Clearly, it's not a plan from eternity
past like Peter's preaching in the book
of Acts.
The plan that God had always had to work
out where the son was always going to
be.
And notice she diminishes Christ by
saying the father couldn't be seen. His
glory was too great to behold. But ah
Jesus, nah, he could be seen.
These are all the ways that evidence
that no, they're not trinitarians. They
have a different Jesus. This is a
serious issue.
But this is in the chapter of the book
titled the plan of salvation.
After man fell, Jesus proposes a plan
for man to be redeemed, which involved
Jesus incarnating, giving his life a
ransom to give mankind a second
probation like Adam and Eve were on. And
then through the merits of Christ's
blood and their obedience to the Ten
Commandments, man could be returned to a
position of favor with God, eventually
returning to Eden.
Sorry, Adventists. Eternity is not a
return to Eden. Nor are the Ten
Commandments how one has favor with God.
This is a false gospel and a false
Christ.
And just to further demonstrate that
yes, Jesus proposed a plan that the
father apparently wasn't already aware
of, which is why Jesus was pleading.
Spirit of Prophecy, Volume 1, page 47,
same book. She goes on to say, "Jesus
bade the heavenly host to be reconciled
to the plan that his father accepted.
and rejoice that fallen man could be
exalted again through his death to
obtain favor with God and enjoy heaven.
Close quote. What did she say two pages
earlier was what brought favor with God?
Obedience to the Ten Commandments plus
Jesus's merits. And this plan was
accepted by the father. That's not how
Paul describes reconciliation like we
saw earlier.
There are so many christoologgical
issues with all of this.
Very clearly the father and the son
don't share in the same knowledge. They
have a level of separation at that level
that does not comport with the
trinitarianism.
The triune God is not divided like this.
But after this happens, now notice what
she claims regarding Satan in his
response to this plan. Three pages
later,
Satan again rejoiced with his angels
that he could by causing man's fall
pulled down the Son of God from his
exalted position.
He told his angels that when Jesus
should take fallen man's nature, he
could overpower him and hinder the
accomplishment of the plan of salvation.
Close quote.
Oh, no. No. She didn't teach that Jesus
was exalted to be made equal with the
father. She just repeatedly said that he
was and that after Satan tempted man in
Eden, he rejoiced because he felt he was
able to what?
Pull Jesus down from his exalted
position. This is prior to the creation
of the earth, folks.
This is not Jesus as a man post
incarnation.
No, there was an exalted position like
James White recognized earlier because
of Ellen and what we just read where
Jesus was exalted prior to the creation
of the earth, then incarnates, and then
there's another exaltation as a man
where he's exalted.
This is after God the Father calls
together the heavenly host to make the
announcement and confer special honor
onto Jesus. Page 17, making him equal
with himself.
This is after Satan was jealous of this
exaltation and wondered why he wasn't
the one chosen to be exalted. Yeah.
Because he's a creature and Jesus is
Yahweh. Jesus was never exalted to be
made equal with Yahweh when he's Yahweh.
Yes. Very clearly over and over this
narrative revolves around the Adventist
Jesus being exalted to be made equal
with the father. Lucifer being jealous,
rebelling, attacking the character of
God, which they mean the Ten
Commandments, and starting the great
controversy, which is the central hinge
of their entire worldview.
Jesus being exalted to be made equal
with the father is central to the whole
paradigm.
Yet, it's not true. is a different Jesus
that's not real, an idol, a figment of
this woman's imagination that was
clearly influenced by Joseph Smith and
John Milton, Paradise Lost.
But more evidence of the divided,
confused Adventist heavenly trio as well
as the false Christ of Adventism. This
is her commentary immediately after the
resurrection. Notice what she says.
quote, "Supposing that he was the
gardener, she begged him," talking about
Mary, "if he had borne away her Lord,
to tell her where he had laid him, and
that she might take him away. Jesus
spoke to her with his own heavenly
voice, saying,"Mary." She was acquainted
with the tones of that dear voice, and
quickly answered, "Master." And in her
joy was about to embrace him. But Jesus
said, "Touch me not, for I am not yet
ascended to my Father, but go to my
brethren and say unto them, I ascend
unto my Father and your Father, and to
my God and your God." John 20:17.
Joyfully she hastened to the disciples
with the good news. Jesus quickly
ascended to his father to hear from his
lips that he accepted the sacrifice and
to receive all power in heaven and on
earth. Close quote.
So after he resurrected,
the Adventist Jesus didn't know if his
sacrifice had been accepted. This is
supposedly why in John 2017, Jesus told
Mary not to cling to him because he
didn't know yet if his sacrifice was
accepted and if he was worthy of
worship.
So he secretly ascended to heaven and
had to hear from the lips of the father
that it was accepted. Again, God the
Father now has lips.
He has parts
because the Adventist father is
basically a man.
But again, we see that the Adventist
Jesus is not omnisient.
Furthermore, Ellen White had an abysmal
understanding of scripture because like
we saw earlier in Romans 1:4, Jesus was
declared to be the son of God by his
resurrection.
Outside of the fact that Jesus himself
said definitively that he would
resurrect himself, his sacrifice was
obviously accepted because if it wasn't,
he wouldn't have been resurrected.
He would have been just like any other
sinner that never resurrects yet until
Christ resurrects the the the fallen
person.
He would have remained in the tomb and
it would have been evident that he was
it would have been evidence that he was
a fraud. But the fact that he did
resurrect proved he was who he said he
was, the divine son of God, the one whom
the scriptures foretold of, God in
flesh, who would come and establish his
everlasting kingdom, redeem the fallen
creation, and rule and reign supreme
forever in all of the universe, all of
creation. He would be supreme in union
with his people forever. We didn't look
at any of those verses, which we could
have. all the various places in the Old
Testament that talk about Yahweh coming.
Yahweh is going to come and establish
his kingdom. He's going to rule and
reign with a dominion and everlasting
kingdom that knows no ends. All of that
stuff is then said in the new New
Testament about Jesus.
Furthermore, scripture knows nothing
about two ascension events.
Ellen should have should have cross-
refferenced more carefully because Mary
falls down and does touch Jesus at the
same event that Ellen's commenting on
but not in John in the accounting in
Matthew 28. She clings to his feet. It
says it's very obvious that Jesus was
saying to not cling to him because he
was on a divine timeline. His ascension
had yet to take place. He had to be seen
by the eyewitnesses etc. He had a
schedule. He didn't just resurrect and
it's like, "Oh, okay.
All right. Now what?" No, he he still
had a He was on a divine timeline in the
incarnation postresurrection. He's still
on a timeline.
So, he's saying, "I haven't ascended
yet. I'm on a timeline." Not, "Don't
touch me. I have to find out if I uh my
sacrifice was even accepted."
He wasn't telling them he's not worthy
of worship because he hadn't heard if
his sacrifice was accepted from the lips
of the father. which is why most modern
translations will say he told them not
to cling to him. And the word cling has
to do with holding in place. They were
obstructing the agenda. Basically, not
something about him lacking knowledge.
But speaking of these two ascensions,
let's not forget the Adventist Jesus had
multiple second comingings, too.
The SDA church's big focus is supposed
to be the second coming. Look at this
quote. In the days of the early
Christians, Christ came the second time.
His first advent was at Bethlehem when
he came as an infant. His second advent
was at the aisle of Patmos when he
revered himself or revealed himself in
glory to John the revelator who fell at
his feet as dead when he saw him. Close
quote.
So technically, Patmos should have been
the third coming. The second would have
been his secret ascension after the
resurrection to find out if he actually
was who he said he was. And then if you
read the the I I read from the story of
redemption quote there, but if you read
the parallel of it in Desire of Ages,
she says, "And then he returned into a
sin uh a sinridden world to to you know
to see the disciples." Okay. Well, that
would have been his second coming. His
third coming then would have been this
visit to Patmos. So the SDA church
should be all about the fourth coming,
not the second. As if it even needs
said. Ellen G. wife arch heretic
cuz she went so far as to make the silly
decision to attribute her foolishness to
God and violate the third commandment
repeatedly.
But to circle back around to our thesis,
this was who God raised up to restore
his church.
That mess,
we just scratched the surface. We didn't
even talk about all the other subjects.
No, the God of scripture, his church
never never became totally apostate,
needed to be restored. We're going to be
talking about the preservation of the
church here coming up quickly because
it's not just SDAs that that make this
this charge. You've then got the inverse
charge, which is often made by our Roman
Catholic friends, Orthodox friends, that
that's what Protestants believe when no,
that's not what Protestants believe.
And even if it did, he didn't use
christoologgical anti-trinitarian
heretics that didn't even believe in him
to do that effort.
Folks, you have modern SDA scholarship
such as Jerry Moon arguing that the
pioneers grew over time and changed,
including Ellen White. You have the
anti-heavenly trio proponents claiming
that's false. Which is why within
Adventism you have confusion
at such a fundamental level as to who it
is they even worship.
But since they were too prideful and had
to reinvent the wheel, claiming everyone
else is just a dunce of Roman
Catholicism, they ended up producing
rotten fruit for decades now. A total
mess at the fundamental level.
When the SDA church tries to tell us
that they are the commandment keeping
church, no you're not. No, you're not.
You're kidding yourselves. You think,
"Oh, look, see, we keep the seventh day
Sabbath and and none of them do, so they
they agree with nine." And No, you are
kidding yourselves. You're kidding
yourselves.
They are a sect that uses Christian
language and proof texts from all over
the Bible to try and uphold the
imagination of a woman from the 19th
century that claimed to be in direct
communication with God who was also a
product of her time.
They have a false god even to this day.
both the pioneers and the modern day.
You have two idols going back and forth
butdding heads which means they're in
violation of all four of the first of
the ten commandments which are all
god-facing. They have an idol that they
proilitize. A Jesus that was only a man
while on earth who was exalted to be
made equal with the father prior to the
creation of the earth. That's not
actually the almighty.
Because when they say the father and the
son have the same nature, they don't
mean equality shared in attribution
as we saw he's not a Jesus. The
Adventist Jesus isn't actually
omnisient. He turned that off like a
light switch.
It's like do you understand the problems
that that would create? It's like that
would mean that Jesus could then do
other things that just are completely
against who he is by nature.
They can't say this without saying Ellen
White was wrong. That's the problem,
which will never happen. So instead,
they weave all sorts of theological webs
and play a bunch of word games, hoping
to catch as many unsuspecting flies as
possible, who then get tangled in that
web and can't see their way out. Which
is why, in part, this platform exists.
We are cutting through the SDA
theological fog to make these
distinctions more clear and to highlight
the theological dangers of this movement
to Christians. The general level of
awareness has got to raise, folks. We
got millions of people here on a a a
dangerous pathway. Are all Adventists
lost? No.
But this platform is dealing with the
organization,
the official stated beliefs.
Not all SDAs are bad people. That's not
what we're saying here. Contrary to the
plethora, and when I say plethora, I
mean plethora of hate mail that we
receive weekly
that says the contrary. We don't hate
SDAs. Not even close. It's the exact
opposite.
I'm willing to shoot the, you know,
shoot the truth to you straight,
trusting that God will use it for his
purposes. And it's really as simple as
that. If Adventists were honest, they
would say, "Yes, you're an apostate,
Miles, and you're lost." One of us is
brave enough to actually say the quiet
part out loud and shoot it straight,
knowing that it's going to lead to all
sorts of vitriol and anger sent my
direction. You're doing this to be
famous. Yeah. Yeah.
Cuz this is what you Yeah.
But despite that, I'm still firm enough
in my conviction and care for SDAs that
I want them to come know the truth.
That's what this is actually about. Not
being famous, not dogging on SDAs.
We want you to come to know the true
God. The true gospel.
You can't divorce those two things from
one another. If you have a false god,
you got a false gospel because the
gospel, Galatians 1:12, is the true
God's gospel. And if you have a false
Christ, you don't have the true God.
Which is why this area as well as the
gospel, christologology, all of that
stuff is interconnected. That's the
foundation of the Christian faith,
folks.
The apostles creed,
it is trinitarian in nature. The three
stanzas talk about the three persons,
etc. This is the foundation of the
Christian faith. We've got to be
reaching Adventists with the truth.
We've got to be. I hope tonight was
beneficial for you. It was long. This is
probably the longest stream to date, but
it was necessary.
No, the SDA church is not trinitarian.
They never have been. And what they've
shifted to now is just a different idol
because they're refusing to spray the
theological uh theological glyphosate on
the roots of the movement because they
know what that will result in.
May the triune God continue to use this
platform for his glory and draw many who
are being deceived by this movement out
of it into the truth. Just want to
remind you guys you can join our members
section that is newly on the channel if
you just go to our YouTube homepage.
There will be a button there that says
join. You can click that join, get
access to exclusive content. We will be
adding uh more tiers, what they're
called, uh various levels that you can
join at that will have various perks,
etc. Definitely check that out. come
connect with us. I want to get involved
uh more with you all in the uh members
community section on there, if you will.
Um yeah, as always, until next time, God
bless.
[Music]